didn't see this oh hello
welcome to the h3 podcast after dark
where things get a little dicey a little
wild and of course this is when ela
joins us so it's everybody's favorite
episode
ela who's looking
oh it does okay i thought they were just
hanging down
you can take it off you can take it off
you can drop it
and you can put them back on i love it
apparently av
has the same sunglasses are they like
amazon glasses are they right
no nice glasses excuse me
these are ray bans oh but you don't have
the chain
are yours are ravens oh those aren't
ravens
oh no those look like valentino oh
[ __ ] those are like hell at night a
little above my beard i realized that he
left
holy [ __ ] and kind of like i said i
thought you got those on
amazon yeah i heard that wow
here's what i know wow
shame on me that's my vibe though
something that you kind of like you
don't know if it was ten dollars
or maybe i don't know
[Laughter]
so bougie over here you look bomb though
dude good thing
it's awesome anyway today's episode is
sponsored by liquid iv we have a really
fun episode today
super excited first of all
while we're live the auction of the
legendary
one of one vape god coin is going to
expire
so we're gonna find out does anybody
care it expires in one hour and eight
minutes
current top bid is two hey
carlos is on the edge of his seat 2.69
ethereum five thousand dollars we're
gonna find out
what this thing is worth so i hope i am
so
excited so i hope all of our high
rollers are what tuning in
because this is 101 baby it's the video
vape nation video i don't know what it
means but
that's what it is it's gotta be worse
more than that right
[Laughter]
we're gonna be keeping an eye on that uh
the president ladies and gentlemen is
gonna be calling in
the president of the united states is
gonna be calling in a little bit
yes or sorry that not the pr the
ex-president
donald trump the former president former
president
is the correct honorific
i think actually technically you're
still supposed to call an ex-president
the president like they get that title
for life president trump
i've seen that on the news well he's not
currently the sitting president
yeah but they still refer to him as
president okay
but is he the president no yeah
so we have one of the things the queen
and like
the mama queen and the they're they're
they're all queen but there's like queen
and there's
dog queen right all women are queens but
then there's
so president trump is calling in uh to
discuss his thoughts on
what's going on with david delbrick and
dom i'm really curious what
what he has to think what he has to say
about all that it sucks that he's not on
twitter anymore and we can't
hear about it directly because he has no
outlet right he's been following the
drama and yeah he probably has
he's banned from pretty much all social
media so this is yeah
so we're giving him we're giving them a
platform they call them dumps
they sure do um we also have the kraken
exchange ceo calling in because
apparently he said that we're a bunch of
ignoramuses when it comes to crypto and
we got a lot of stuff
like okay come on explain you know
talk to him while the well the bid goes
down
it'll be fun exciting you feel the
energy buzzing
i am so excited i am so happy
wait oh i was like what's up you know
teddy fresh we did a new collection
yesterday and
there's nothing left so don't don't go
no i mean there's some stuff left but
like we're really happy though because
we
uh we spent a lot of time actually on
these pieces even though they're so
simple looking um and also
all the women's fits we spent a lot of
time
like perfecting it so i'm happy that it
all
you know was successful it's really cool
um
it's not our intention to have like it
be so scarce it just kind of surprised
us on the demand for this stuff
yeah but we're gonna restock it so if
you missed it don't worry they'll be
back on the website we're gonna
uh relatively soon you know it takes a
minute but we're gonna
we're gonna restock all this stuff not
so soon it takes time because i see
everyone's asking like care bears friend
is it
time so the cl okay well anyway we're
working on getting more classics that
you know
where there's also another drop coming
out next week
on thursday just a few more pieces that
that's just gonna happen a lot this year
because of covid everything is just just
thrown off so um instead of having it
all come out together some pieces were
delayed so
next week so you have a chance to pick
some stuff up next week but there's
still some stuff you know like this
shirt is [ __ ] i
this shirt i should be wearing this
shirt why am i not wearing this shirt
this shirt is so sick
yeah re-roll it's a terry shirt it's a
goddamn shirt named terry
oh was that anyway there's that
congratulations elon another slammer
thank you you know i i
we've been talking a lot about the
justice league
and i have to say a lot of us were being
like
well pretty much all of us said
unanimously that this is going to be
horrible in fact it holds a coveted
title
amongst our highlight clips as one of
the most disliked
was that about the original one though
um
i don't think it's one of the most i
think it is the most
disliked right ian justice league hd
podcast highlights is it really
of all the things i [ __ ] said and
done
this is the one this one you crossed the
line ethan
so yeah yeah really crossed a lot okay
so yeah
i think we were talking about
j we called it justice league as tryhard
i think that title this year
because it was like that title is
ridiculous yeah
i agree i don't know if that was my
title or
i'm sure i feel like i want to blame
that on dan
try hard garbage i didn't name it
actually i could see that
yeah i mean i agree with it but i didn't
name it
i didn't pick that title people are so
mad because they care so much about it
it's almost like good man but anyway
okay
[Laughter]
it was also one titled justice league
will be horrible
how did that one do let's see it's in
the discord
oh you sent me that one too okay well
here let me just type it on here justice
league will
be horrible let's see how people
received this one two weeks ago yeah
your face
bro you got this oh whoa this one's even
worse
oh my god this just happened yeah this
is from two weeks ago
wow do i dare you really no i'm scared
i didn't even know it went so bad are
they gonna get super personal on me
absolutely have you read any of these
not on that one let me peek let me pee
i'm not showing that's how it starts the
fever the rage is the feeling
oh he's meaning i think that's a line
from the movie or something
oh not to nothing too this guy looks
like he's falling asleep any second he's
talking about me i probably was tired
okay oh this they go how's this guy
gonna watch a four-hour movie with an
open mind but can't even watch your
trailer properly
i'm sorry what's a proper way to watch a
trailer bro
you [ __ ] explain well anyway it came
out last night and i watched the [ __ ]
i watched the whole damn thing all four
[ __ ] hours you actually got all the
way through
i watched i finished it wow at like
three a.m
because i started at like you know ten i
was like all right i could stay up to
two but then you have to go to the
bathroom you get a snack
you take the dogs out you know four
hours of long-ass time to sit still
what am i doing i started watching with
ethan and i watched maybe 10 minutes and
then i was like okay i get it but
i could make better use of my i was like
what do you get and
i watched the real housewives of beverly
hills
for the whole time i came upstairs and
she was like laying there and i thought
she was sleeping so i got ready for bed
and i come out and her eyes are open
i was like you're watching real
housewives of everything hill this whole
[ __ ]
four or five hours zero regret about
that
any good drama unfold of course nice
camille's house burned down oh that
sucks that's not drama that's just
horrible
yeah and everyone fought with camille
she's living oh and
lvp has left the show oh she's out they
never reconciled she's out
whoa real housewives pops off
okay so did who else watched this before
i give my opinion on
the the snyder the schneider snidey
who else watched the whole thing i
watched it
ian did you make it through hold on let
me fix my camera really quick
to be a little more
i'd appropriate a little color
correction a little square
i fell asleep i'm i'm sorry i tried well
you started out
you started at like 12 dude i know
i know well i was like you're gonna be
up to four a.m at least this is what the
movie looks like to anyone who doesn't
get this okay so so let me get let me
share my thoughts
because i'm out here getting disliked
into oblivion yeah
put my neck out i watched all four hours
here's what i'm gonna say about it
it was pretty good really yeah it's
pretty good no spoilers
by the way the exception of like a few
almost intolerably corny moments you
know
yeah i'm surprised you said that because
i'd say the first like hour that you
were watching it you were repeatedly
messaging us with like what the [ __ ] is
this movie
yeah i mean they must have really turned
it around at some point there were
certain well there's just certain
moments where you're like
why do they make it so [ __ ] corny
like every time a girl get though it
shows up on screen and it's like
oh oh yeah the music like there's like
amazonians like
and everything's in slow motion and
then like um just every shot it's like
when aquaman's in the shot he has to
back up
slowly into the water or there's always
so many close-ups of like gal gadot or
whoever being like
superman or just you know it's like
unbearably corny
that being said for a four-hour movie
i thought that i didn't actually mind
the length
because you know in a lot of these
movies they try to tell so much story in
like two hours and you're like
that there was no [ __ ] pacing that
was
a nightmare so actually i thought you
know with the amount of story they're
trying to pack
in that it was pretty good and i didn't
mind the length
the only part i hated i'm not going to
give out a spoiler
is the ending which and i think i i
don't think i'm spoiling anything
because i've seen all over social media
people know that jared leto made a cameo
jared let his joker in the cameo and so
i saw people on twitter being like jared
leto
has proving himself to be the true joker
i was like no no
way i buy this so anyway i'm watching
i'm watching and at the very end he
makes his little cameo
and that was the worst part of the film
by far by far
by far i mean i i honestly
i until i thought this is a really good
movie i i even say really good
up until the last you know 20 minutes
and i was like this is no longer a
really good movie this is a good movie
you know what i mean
it went down a point jared leto is by
far the cringiest joker he's horrible
uh he's proved he's doubled down on the
whole
yeah he somehow maybe you said i think
it's true he somehow made his laugh even
worse than it was in the
it's just he literally goes
i swear to god that's how he laughs
oh my god he doesn't break it up anymore
he doesn't go
ah he goes it's just yeah
but i just it's horrible so but with
peace and love
to jared leto you were the worst joker
and the worst part of the movie
other than that i thought it was really
cool i thought it was good okay
i like the perspective you get on all
the individual
characters and the culmination of the
story i thought was very nice
nice i like it yeah did you like the by
three ratio
i didn't mind it cool well at first i
was like i like it
i was like who makes a four by three
four hour movie about superheroes i was
like [ __ ] this is not
schindler's list
but then dan explained that it was like
for imax and i was like okay
it makes sense i didn't mind it nice
so there you have it [ __ ] eat my ah
eating my words man
it's a pretty good movie you know
um but dan i feel like you're the
biggest hater so you need to watch that
yeah i'll probably check it out over
this weekend right
maybe i didn't feel like watching a
four-hour movie yeah no i know i don't
blame you
go ahead ab what do you think oh yeah i
agree with what you said yeah pretty
much
yeah it got better as it went on but the
ending was kind of
unnecessary bro the last the ending
apparently i'm not gonna again i'm not
spoiling but
apparently they re-shot all the ending
and that was like a big deal that he
it was so unnecessary bro you did not
need that it was
so stupid it was [ __ ] horrible do you
understand what i'm saying
horrible it's just so unnecessary
bruh bruh oh my god
[Applause]
you know i'm not going to talk about
david dobrik today but everybody likes
that no it's just one comment
that we all enjoyed that we agreed we
should read somebody said oh that was my
favorite david dobrik
asked his fans to piece together a
puzzle i don't think he expected it to
be this one
i missed the mark with that one okay
yeah you might say so
there's so much more stuff coming out
there's gonna be a lot to follow on that
story i think cuz like
there's just a lot of similar stories as
to the one that was covered in that
article coming out like
identical stories yeah so this was
just the tip of the iceberg in my
opinion that was a good impression dan
we've been looking for james charles
impressionist but i don't know if we
need one
keep going
can you say hi sisters today i'm going
to be doing a foundation tutorial hi
sisters today i'm going to be doing a
foundation tutorial
yeah the problem with the james charles
impressions you don't want to sound like
you're doing
a caricature of like a super flamboyant
gay person because that's like offensive
but it's weird because that's what he
sounds like that's how he speaks
it's tough yeah that is so true that is
something
[Laughter]
but we're looking for a perfect james
charles impersonator
i know you're out there
the depths of james charles videos
um there was a lot of people worried
about shredder i just want to
con let everybody know that shredder is
fine
people think shredder is dying because i
said that he pukes off doesn't happen
all the time it's not like a daily
occurrence
safe shredder uh well thank you for
being concerned but we've already we've
take
so shredder puke sometimes in the
morning we already took him to the
doctor a while ago the doctor said that
little yorkies like him often have
overactive
um bile so
she said you know if he doesn't eat for
a minute
he can over produce uh stomach acids and
you know it's something that happens
with dogs like this so we've taken him
in he got all the tests and everything
he's fine
that we've he this has been going on for
a while yeah he's been going
he's good shredder's good don't worry
about shredder but thank you for your
concern
peace and love
peace and love abe's birthday today i
have so many uh things to talk about
here
abe happy birthday how old are you
birthday thank you
i am 5 29 so you are
16 years away from a doctor doing a
prostate exam on you
just about having a finger in your ass
or yeah 45 yeah
so that's exciting can't wait for like
semen
is it really just a finger yeah i've had
i've had a finger in my ass for a hernia
check it doesn't sound that bad it
wasn't that bad and they exaggerated
i went into the doctor he goes okay lay
on your side
because apparently you get in the fetal
position
which feels a little like compromising
you're like a grown-ass man getting in
the fetal position
he puts on a glove he puts some lube and
he just he goes in
wiggles around it wasn't that bad and
people people exaggerate
although i've never had a prostate exam
so i don't know if that's deeper
or more wiggling or i don't
so uh do anything fun maybe any plans
no not really hanging out at home
playing my playstation
nice and safe yeah love that
happy birthday thank you
so are you kidding me
so the other thing i want to talk before
we kind of get underway
you know dave david has been like fully
canceled okay at this point or like it's
happening i don't know
to what extent it will go but this
really kind of [ __ ] upset me
is that james charles meanwhile who in
my opinion is
i don't think we need to say who is
worse or who is better right
right because i know we don't know what
you're trying we don't need to play the
olympics
yeah the olympics game but he just put
out a collaboration with dream
corps husband and pewdiepie and a bunch
more including by the way
a 16 year old minecraft player
oh timmy in it oh no
now how is it
that this is possible when he admitted
himself that he was
sexting and exchanging nudes with a
[ __ ]
16 year old boy it's such a bizarre
world
it's just people like we just finished
watching the
allen of earth pharaoh yeah woody the
woody allen documentary
hi sisters which was so hard to watch um
but you see how like people it's just
easier to believe that they didn't do it
don't want to think that people are so
bad or that they would do something bad
and it's like you feel like you're
already trusted i mean he admitted on
twitter
you know what i mean at least woody like
yeah i know what you mean
but or i'm assuming these people must
just not know
which i guess is possible yeah because
look at you you have to really follow
all the stories
it's like overwhelming likes this you
know what i mean people are stoked
but when they come here and they co-sign
charles james charles they say oh
it's okay to associate with him the dude
is a known predator
straight up yeah like you're saying the
woody allen thing it's really disturbing
because you can see how
long he got away with it his whole life
woody allen
literally assaulted his own daughter and
members of his family
and all the and there was other [ __ ]
going on too
he never had to account for that he went
on to win all these awards work with all
these actors make all these movies
he started this whole campaign of
attacking his wife as if it's all her
fault
and people followed that you know they
just buy that
yeah it was it was dude the documentary
is really good it's very disturbing
though so
definitely a trigger warning on that
documentary but it was really good
very disturbing and it just makes me
think like
we all think there's like this huge
change like me too and stuff
you're like oh how could that happen
with woody allen or roman polanski or uh
harvey weinstein it's like dude it's
happening right here on youtube before
our [ __ ] eyes
well let's not forget that me too was
pretty recent
you know so it takes time well but
they even touched on that because the
his daughter
when she first wrote an essay of um
what happened to her and published it
people weren't ready for that it was
before me
too and then after me too she published
it again and then there was a real
response to it so right i don't know it
takes time
like society is just not ready for this
stuff
i just don't know what to make of this
like dream
corpse husband and pewdiepie all
collaborating with james
one week after he admitted to preying on
a young boy
which is a pattern of behavior that you
know he does and all these people have
predominantly younger fans too
so they're they're literally putting
their fans in harm's way
um the fact that something someone like
woody allen can exist
in our midst in our own community and
the same thing happening
history repeating itself in the same way
is
is a a terrifying thought
because i don't know it's just it's it's
it's it's disturbing
i was just going to his channel to see
kind of what he was up to
and i was like what all these people
are co-signing james charles right after
this happened i don't get it
these are like the biggest creators on
the platform
and chipotle one of the biggest brands
still the videos up right
highest like they didn't you know yeah
i mean if dave if david why not james
james came out and said it happened
right on [ __ ] twitter
sister it's disturbing man it's
upsetting
he's a [ __ ] he's a predator
okay okay let's lighten it up here
okay let's lighten it up with a little
bit of windy
remember it's not wendy williams it's
wendy williams because she passes wind
you like that it's okay pound it
thank you all right you guys know you
all remember wendy
pass gas uh epically legendarily
oh no i put the cat out of the bag wait
i wanted to show
the original fart gate oh deal
look at her look at that lean vote she
knows she's about to pass gas
this is the the original fart gate sold
you're old enough to understand
political correctness in the times that
we live
now you can't just slap people on the
booty
yeah of course he probably knows it's
not right
to a man but you can't even do that
locker room thing
that cop wasn't playing that i mean
you're lucky it sounds fake but i
guarantee you we've isolated that sound
by if you've watched the show for a long
time you know we love that sound bite
zach hit it
[Music]
that's literally the sound she made
right here you can listen
okay you only got battery oh
i'm playing that i mean
you're lucky you only got such a gnarly
rip
so that's wendy williams now there's a
new
fart gate going around where she burps
and then farms
at the same time now we're gonna open
this clip we're gonna watch it
we've isolated the sound bite obviously
and we're gonna debate
and see what exactly is going on so here
listen closely my friends she's not
lonely
[Applause]
i love her she's like oh jesus christ
she's not lonely
all right zach so so can you
play that you know give me some gain
give me some
give me some maybe even go ahead
can you slow it down a little bit
i mean what's their debate well zach
doesn't think that the uh
the fart is a fart what is it i don't
think it's a fart i think
she's burped and she's trying to cover
herself up so she goes she burps and go
oh
like she's not good interesting let me
watch she's not lonely
it's so weird though that's a [ __ ]
dude where's the sound coming so it's so
hard but
i think it's it's hard to burp and fart
at the same time unless you like are
super sick
like one of you burped and farted like
consecutive well
she might have some kind of condition
you know that may be true
but i don't know well i don't know she's
up here apart and burping it's happening
all the time i mean
i can see if you so let's say you burp
and you get surprised your body tense up
you slip one out but wouldn't you suck
up when you put
like no the gas is there
it's just a little one you know what i
mean it's just a little uh little toot
yeah it's not like a rock i think i
think she just went
with her mouth she's not lonely that's
just my opinion okay
i feel like if we zoom on her face
why does it not let me zoom okay wait i
know how to zoom hang on
all right all right do you really think
so like let's wat
there's unless she's like jeff dunham
doing like ventriloquy i don't know
hey paul she's not lonely
when does she make that sound with their
mouth yeah i i don't
if you look like also how do you make
that sound
you can make that sound with your mouth
but your mouth is clear
that's not the sound it has a pitch to
it
it has appeared here here's the part
that sounds like a tooth to me it sounds
like a part
she's not all right mindy we've heard a
wendy williams fart before
just you know she was ripping ass that
time that time she had a lot of gas
she knew she had to fart you see the
angle she was hitting
her his cheeks were clapping on that one
i don't but
not this one though can we get a straw
pull up i'm curious what the people
think
sure one second i don't see her mouth
going
i've just i've heard enough farts before
and like
i don't know it just doesn't hey zach
i'm older than you i've heard more farts
okay when are you the fart expert i
don't know
i've i've ripped some pretty gnarly
farts and i'm not denying you of
but you're saying okay dude somewhat
that makes you a fart expert
she's not lonely
all right the polls up i pinned it and
i'm spamming it in the chat so
all right you guys tell me what you
think i feel like
what are you gonna vote here oh can you
drop it in the
description well it's obviously a fart
but
maybe people maybe you know
maybe people see it differently and so
i'm interested to know
it's making me verify come on what are
you voting you
well i don't think i should say i'm not
seeing any
results yeah me neither
you know a bunch of websites have been
having issues today oh yeah yeah
straw poll is uh not working huh
what's the wendy keeper oh she's
sabotaging the sound bite
just keep playing the fart
it let me vote but it's just not uh
showing any results
oh it just it just like went through and
then play me the original fart
there we go yeah and then play me the
new part just play just hit me with it
let me think on it
[Music]
play the old one
yeah keep it going
well
[Music]
the overwhelming majority is yes on this
[Music]
one
holy [ __ ] i just spilled
so much water on myself
at least it didn't get on the
electronics i don't think so
that was the biggest water spill ever
okay what do we need you need a towel
holy [ __ ]
dude what do we do here
i just spilled like a whole game like a
big cup
this much water i probably could use a
new shirt
sure i mean i'm so okay
damn that was intense and none of these
electronics are wet right
i think it was like the best spot
okay wow
stand by here for a moment here guys
holy damn i shouldn't put my cup there
right in the path of the arm
thank you thank you dan
we have less than 40 minutes in the
auction oh [ __ ]
well so wait we have to take a break and
then yeah it's actually it's a break
time now
and then we're gonna have the president
call in and then have we gotten any new
bids or nobody cares
there was uh it's well i guess you
already showed
there hasn't been a 269. uh
no actually it went up it's at 282 now
oh there was a bed okay
oh mine's not updated so what's fun is
that um
when there's a new bid it extends the
timer by 10 minutes
oh so we could get into a potential
bidding war here
oh interesting thank you guys for your
help on that
all right let's let's cut to the ad
break get trump on the phone and then
we'll
talk to the kraken
sorry shredder freak shredder out
wow all right what do we got liquid iv
you
dan you wanna cool crap hit me with that
metal
dan crack open a liquid iv tell me about
it
you just sip that [ __ ] as i read this
dan's been hitting that liquid iv
at home hitting it hard hitting it hard
you go he walks in you know i've been
hitting
liquid iv and i like it i'm into it
we got a passion fruit one right here
listen liquid iv is going to help you
become a better version of you
fitness routine staying hydrated
whatever it is it can help
one goal for myself is to stay more
hydrated or to drink less soda and
caffeine you know or
coffee because it's bad for my stomach
so you get the caffeine boost
liquid iv and you are raging
you know what i mean you don't need
anything that [ __ ]
hit it dan that packet goes in the cup
you s yes you stir the damn thing
yes baby listen what do i like about
liquid iv
the taste the function the how easy it
is to use
it's less polluting than [ __ ] you
know every time you want to get a
some other kind of energizing drink you
have to buy it in like a bottle or some
[ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah nah nah nah
first thing in the morning before a
workout when you feel run down
get your daily hydration maintenance
you're for a hangover
for hangover cure etc etc you know what
it is
so what's your favorite flavor dan you
like the watermelon one you say
uh actually the one that i had just now
passion proof oh it's really good yeah
so is that the
boost the immune boost one no this one's
just a hydration multiplier
oh okay so you're just getting all
jacked up on water just
john freaking i'm not i'm like moses
over here
yo did you guys know that one serving a
liquid iv provides the same hydration of
drinking two to three bottles of water
alone
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and there's less sugar
than a freaking apple dude
made with clean ingredients it's non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy or soy
you don't want soy though because you're
not a soy boy
i don't know that's not they didn't
write that just for clarity
yeah those are the opinions expressed by
me and not
so grab your strawberry liquid iv
or other great flavors in bulk
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com and use code
h3 at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you use the
promo code h3
at liquidity.com
promo code h3 get better hydration today
at liquid.com
promo code liquidity.com
promo code h3 was that clear
liquidity.com promo code h3
got him okay so how much time do we have
on the
on the um on the auction
uh uh it ends in 34 minutes wow okay
this is coming up
fast so let's get the president on the
phone because i know i don't want to
keep him waiting i know he's busy
um uh yeah is he ready to go he's a busy
guy
uh hey hey i think i do see him in the
waiting room so um just stand by let me
set up so yeah i mean you know i know
i know um donald's son
from back in the day uh a friend of mine
went to the same country club
and yada you know so i happen to have it
in with the president
can i get some of your water so i can
spill it all over the room again
actually i have another so i'm very
privileged and honored
to say to say welcome mr
president hello can everybody hear me
yeah we can hear you
i feel i sound good tremendous i snuck
back into the white house for this
because this is such a big deal
right i appreciate that hello ethan
and ela that's a tremendous name and i
know names
because i married a slovenian woman so
ethan you and i have a latin cabinet oh
yeah
very nervous turns to gold we and we
love
immigrants we love the immigrant people
tremendous people
so uh of a son his name's teddy fresh is
that your son's name teddy fresh yeah
well his name is theodore
yeah theodore great name great thank you
underused name by the way
underused name well thank you for
acknowledging that mr president
i'm so glad that you're able to make the
time to come out here today uh it's it's
quite an honor
i wanted to bring you in to um
to ask you if you've been following the
whole david dobrik thing i know you've
had some allegations yourself so i
thought maybe you would have an
interesting perspective
on what's going on david is an
absolutely fantastic kid he's a smart
kid he's an attractive kid he's always
smiling
he's always he's always up to some
shenanigans or something like that
he likes that he likes to be close to
where people are having sex and i think
that's a good thing
right i think that's a good thing you
know what i mean everyone has their
friend
i look at him as a young as a young
jeffrey upstairs
wow that doesn't sound like a compliment
mr president
well were you ever at any of jeffrey's
parties this guy had great parties
right right and he hangs out with that
weird guy nash
these guys always have another guy you
know they made
another guy and another guy that's so
interesting observation
but so you think he you do you think
david is kind of like guilty
should we cancel david i mean people are
saying that he facilitated
some kind of assault so i mean what
should be the punishment for somebody
like david
well isn't he currently on an
anti-bullying tour i mean i think that's
more important at this point
don't you think that he should be out
there you know being like be best
right he had a tremendous tremendous
program
on anti-bullying and i don't think
canceling people is good unless i'm
doing it then it's really incredible
harley davidson 18t right you know i
canceled so many people
i cancelled i cancelled rosie o'donnell
for eight
years i mean she had a nervous breakdown
i know how to cancel people
i know how to care to people most people
have no idea how to cancel people you
know what i mean i canceled the nfl can
you believe that
eight sports it's really incredible
right incredible i go big i go big not
just one player
the entire franchise
well that's a good point right now i see
your point
um do you go and so david's doing i
can't i can't get over hello
i mean gee i had no idea there's so much
money on youtube it's really incredible
yeah oh yeah there's lots of money here
um
do you think you think he should be
canceled do you think he should be
cancelled
um that's a tough question i think at
least he should get a haircut
at the very least right well
that's a good observation you know and
then there's this other guy dom
involved right dom so yes
i heard about the dom too so what do we
think about don because david
filmed it but dom's the one who did it
so how do we
what what should we do with dom do you
think well
something is very strange about the
whole dumb thing
i think all of this is very very weird
you know what i mean the way they set
this stuff
up the way all these things happen you
know i don't know do you know what if
he's a republican or a democrat whatever
he is
dom i don't know his political
affiliation because if he's a republican
i'm fine with it but it is a democrat
this is pretty disgusting
really really upsetting you know the
proximity to all these strange things
and i noticed
i noticed i had one of my i had kelly
kelly did a wonderful little quick
wrap up on everything and uh the kissing
the guy's kissing what's going on with
the guys kissing well you know
and i love the gays don't get me wrong
but why is he always setting up this
situation where guys are kissing
all right yeah you're talking about seth
seth
was a guy who thought he was going to be
making out with a girl
but they put the mask on this guy nash
and they
they tricked seth into making out with
nash who but seth thought he was making
out with a girl that's what happened in
that situation
that's very disappointing that's very
disappointing that never happened to me
though but i think it's very
disappointing
so this guy nash is he like uh you know
galen maxwell to jeffrey
epstein yeah
that's a good analogy sure that's a good
analogy
yeah it's a very odd thing maybe maybe
we don't cancel them and we just take
them off the air for the
a little while we get rid of their
corporate sponsors let's see how he does
that
right see how he does that all right
good that's a good point
well um listen it's been fantastic
getting your insight i mean wow
yeah i didn't know you follow all this
topic absolutely and i love the fact
that you love feet
you love feet oh yeah it's really
incredible your foot guy your foot guy
what you called foot wiki or wiki
feet yeah what do you feel no i love
wikileaks i love wikileaks we love
wikipedia
the way i take wikileaks believe me but
i the big thing is wonderful because you
know i've learned two beauty pageants
and i love
love love beautiful woman no one loves
beautiful women the way i love beautiful
women i must i mean i married three of
them
right right right right right um
you're very i mean i appreciate you
coming out i'm surprised you have time
are you still
are you very busy now that uh got
nothing to do
i go off and eat you know and i can't
tweet i can't go on any of the social
media i really have nothing to do
really okay well that explains so i'm
looking for something for that's why i
want to get back into office
that's why i want to get back into
office because i think i could really
turn this country around because sleepy
you know i'm here in the white house i'm
here in the white house sleepy joe's
walking around like
where am i where am i you know he's so
old you know he's over 100 years old a
lot of people don't
know that a lot of people don't know
that but he's really old they
discontinued his blood type
but i have plenty of blood because i'm a
stable genius with a big
brain a huge brain and a very very smart
and my uncle
john trump taught at mit for 40 years so
you're here
okay okay well listen we're not here to
uh campaign necessarily you know
you're sure because it's a great
platform you have many many no no no no
no we're here
i was here well thank you i was really
here just to hear about uh david dobrik
but i'm glad that david david dobrik but
i'm glad but you know he didn't weigh a
bunch of cars
right he did yeah he did he gave away a
bunch of cars i mean that's socialism we
should cancel them just for that right
well that's a good observation there's a
lot of things not
so much socialism with that david dobrik
so if i'm understanding correctly you're
saying
the assault okay the car giveaway not
okay
bad very bad socialism bad socialism bad
right you know and then and the borders
are like swiss cheese right now it's
like swiss cheese it's like fondue
they're just coming over here in droves
and probably
because of the car giveaways that david
he's ruining this country right well
that's interesting observation certainly
mr president
absolutely absolutely i'm a very smart
guy i have a big a
well bahrain glad you have so much free
time in a way in a selfish way because
i'm glad you're able to follow this
drama and
probably i'd like to even if you're if
you're willing to have you even call in
and comment on other topics as as they
unfold if you absolutely
absolutely i love catching up and you
know the thing with me is i'm on i'm on
twitter i had 80 million 90 million
probably more followers than anybody
so someone like david dobrik and his kid
what's it called the vlog squad
yeah vlog squad very horrible name
verbal name really bad marketing here
with the v with the v
very feminine i don't like it you know
the thing is the thing is i have to know
what's going on on social media because
when i come back
it's going to be big it's going to be
bigger whatever you and your audience
well we're going to be we're going to be
working hard to
make sure oh we're going to be making
we're going to be working very hard
again
if they broke it into your compound
we're going to be working very hard to
get your twitter back and to bring you
back
we just actually i kind of think i want
your twitter to stay down so that we can
involve you in the show more i prefer
you when you're bored
thank you thank you yeah when i'm bored
i'm a lot of fun
yes we love when that's fun the way i
have fun believe me believe me you know
hopefully i'll meet up with uh you two
live and in person and
you can be milan she's very nice
you'll have a lot in common a lot yeah
you know yeah
right mr president thank you thank you
so much for having me
down this way this will be your highest
rated episode
ever probably all right all right take
care
thank you guys mr president wow
the president you believe this guy's got
the time on his hand to follow all this
drama
no pretty incredible
actually i kind of got nervous like i
was really talking about it
be respectful you were he goes on and on
with the campaigning i was like all
right
you know um on the reel though
we were just talking to the great what's
his twitter
trumps no this the impressionist
oh uh i thought i had it here
i'll put in the we'll put it in the
description he's a he's an incredible
comedian so funny so funny
so just to recap the official stance of
the uh
of the former president is david is like
his good friend
friend epstein and there's nothing wrong
with that
i think it seemed like his biggest issue
was just with the name of the vlog squad
or that he gives away cars
yeah right oh right he didn't like that
at all oh here it is
if you guys want to know who we're
talking to with your boy
johnny d there you have it
we love him don't we folks you bought
boys
[Laughter]
so um let's get yeah so well let's get
the kraken on the phone because our
our the golden token trump to unleashing
the kraken huh
the coin sale ends in 20 minutes oh it
did go up a bit
let's see we got a bidding war between
okay this is exciting
one of those is jesse yeah he's involved
okay he's got the second highest now so
i am
so excited excited when can i see when
these happen did these all happen
recently it doesn't show the time
yeah they yeah it happened recently
within the last like 15 minutes
because yeah this was where it was
before okay i see okay
interesting we got ashley involved i
don't even know who that is ashley
who's ashley a new contender it's
actually a gentleman
i'm talking to him right now on the
discord oh so why absolutely
oh should we get them all that'd be
interesting if we get them let's talk to
the kraken first
just have these guys duke it out live
this is extremely rare opportunity to
own
a rip now how do we rip this video you
made this
uh ian did you just rip it off youtube
or like what's what's the video file in
here
in here for the vape nation video
uh yeah it's um
some high-tech crypto stuff converters
what a digital is it 1080 like what's
the quality the hd quality of the video
we're talking 720
1080 anywhere from 240 to
now well one thing it's actually in four
by three
snyder style well it is the only one
authentic
certified version so if it's in
240 or 1080 what does it matter right
right
the knowing that counts that's art so
where's the kraken
uh i just spoke to him he actually just
popped into the waiting room so let me
uh
you ready because we can watch a semen
preacher update
um i i told him 115 which was a few
minutes from now but it looks like he is
in the waiting room so
let's bring in the crack
[Music]
we're bringing in the big connect guy i
man if we could get carlos we've tried
i've tried
i've tried i think he's he's hiding in
some southeast asian country
trying to oh actually okay is he do you
know any what's the intel on this guy
ashley is he a serious collector
i mean um does he not want to say
anything about himself
he said he bought a few thousand
ethereum at eight dollars
whoa really yeah he said that
he loves us all very much but he may so
he's like a crypto
he's a crypto uh a mogul yeah he's a
crypto mogul
he bought thousands at eight dollars
what a legend
yeah he said he runs a few finance
businesses good for him
you hear that kraken you got competition
all right
yeah i just pinned him so he's ready do
you mind if i call you the crack
that's fine so we have here um
with us um jesse
i'm sorry jesse powell is that right
that's right first of all thank you for
calling in this is very cool
to be talking to you so you are the seat
are you the founder and ceo of craig of
kraken exchange
i am nice nice ten years
ten years in crypto space wow this is
quite a big
uh company now it's like one of the
really big ones right i mean tell me
about your company a little bit
yeah so we're about 10 years old 1500
people
trading 50 plus coins um you know we're
one of the top
exchanges in in the world uh number one
in europe number two in the us
probably number three globally um
yeah we've been around a long time uh
got got a lot of people
um and uh you know i don't know
it's been it's been a very long road uh
over the last 10 years you know and
it's kind of interesting that nfts are
now all of a sudden
a big thing it just kind of came out of
nowhere um
and it's cool to see that you guys are
getting it into it i'm really looking
forward to the
the frenemies edition oh yes that was
your idea
i saw trisha is cool with it so yeah
once she found out she can make money
then she's cold
i think you guys got to work on the the
tokenomics a bit though and
you know the pumpamentals of your
existing uh
offering is pretty good but you know not
many people can afford like a thousand
dollars or two thousand dollars for
for an nft so i think if you in the next
edition do like the frenemies edition do
like
you know make them like ten dollars you
should do like five thousand at ten
dollars each or something instead of
like
you know five and a thousand well to be
totally frank our goal wasn't
necessarily to
it was more of an experiment to see like
is anyone actually going to buy this
stuff
right yeah i had been pushing for mine
to be priced
low and you you pretty much completely
overruled me and said no we're doing
them at one
yeah well you i
fully admit i was wrong on that i didn't
think anybody was gonna buy any of mine
but
they sold out so there you go it's
exclusive i mean you can still do
you can do two versions right you can
have like the foil animated version and
then you can have like the normal
oh right just like a trading card tell
me
why did you make kraken exchange did you
how do you one of these guys that had
this like premonition
of like this is going to be huge i'm
going all in
i've heard about people like you is that
yeah
pre-crypto um from 2001 to 2011 i had a
company selling virtual items and
currencies for online games
like world of warcraft gold diablo
swords
runescape maplestory you did all these
games so
i was already kind of aware of this
virtual currency world
and people using like the world of
warcraft gold like their bank account
and kids at the at school you know at
the cafeteria
trading a brownie for like five world
warcraft gold and stuff like that and
you know it got me thinking that there's
this whole class of people that just
don't have access to
the regulated financial system you know
like a bank account
you know and when people think of like
the the unbanked they're usually
thinking of like people rural india or
africa but really it's like
everyone under the age of 18 in the
united states is unbanked
and um you know just lots of people all
over the world for whatever reason don't
have access to the banking system
and uh we're increasingly becoming
digital
and more things that you want to buy are
digital and if you don't have like
a credit card like what do you do and
you know kids were using world of
warcraft gold and
bitcoin seems like an evolution of that
something that's not um you know
connected to
like blizzard as a video game developer
who could just ban your account
at any time um bitcoin is something that
anyone can can create a wallet for like
without anyone's permission
um you go directly peer-to-peer so it
solves all of these problems uh for
financial services access
in the world and you know things getting
in the way of people sending payments to
each other so
um it also just seemed like a great
store of value
in that you know we know the dollar is
inflating obviously the government's
printing trillions of dollars
you know like it's nothing and there's
probably trillions more to come so it's
clearly not
a store of value like it's not a place
to actually like save your money because
it's just losing value over time you
know the dollars lost like 99 of its
value over the last hundred years
so uh something something that was like
a safe haven asset you know and yeah
bitcoin is volatile but
obviously over the last 10 years you
know it's up like 5 jillion
so relative to everything else you know
it seems like pretty awesome
i have a fundamental confusion
like why how is it that
it just doesn't seem like a functional
currency to me because
first of all the price fluctuates so
much on a day-to-day basis
that using it as any form of currency
doesn't make sense because one day it
could be worth double and the next day
it could be worth half it's like how can
that be a
a stable currency and then the other
thing is like
it seems like well well spending it is
difficult too
isn't it unless you're buying like you
know nfts which is now
maybe that's part of why nfts are so
popular because people feel like oh i
can spend my
coins on something you know so
so how how can it possibly ever be a a
viable currency with how much it
fluctuates in its value
yeah so the value is like fluctuating
less over time as
as more people come into the space and
there's just more money
in inside of the bitcoin system uh you
know
previously 10 years ago it was moving
you know 100 percent
up and down a day now maybe it moves
like
five ten percent a day so you know you
compare
that's something like uh the currency of
like venezuela or argentina where it's
like just falling in half every day and
you know you gotta
go buy your loaf of bread like before
your your currency falls in half again
um it's definitely an upgrade for that
you know so i think it is harder to see
from
from being in the united states where
inflation historically has been like
fairly low
but there are parts of the world where
their their national currencies just
completely failed
and um they may have no way to get into
to other currencies like you know it
might be that actually like buying or
using dollars in their local
economy is like outlawed so bitcoin is
like
absolutely like a savior to them um but
for us long term
do you see someone like someone being
able to buy a loaf of bread with like
cryptocurrency for sure yeah and they
absolutely are in venezuela
they are right now yeah really how does
a bread vendor take
crypto uh so anyone can can set up a
crypto wallet on their phone
yeah um there's there's a load of crypto
apps
um in in the android play store and in
the ios store
uh you can just search for like bitcoin
wallet or ethereum wallet
uh you'll find like a million apps
anyone can just set up an app and
uh you don't have to sign up or anything
like once you just install the app
the the wallet is on your phone and
anyone can just send you coins directly
so but like
these vendors in venezuela know how to
accept crypto
you know what i mean it's just i guess
maybe in in due time yeah
yeah they they actually do i mean yeah
it seems like you know it's it's a
high-tech thing but i mean it's actually
really simple to set up i mean
it's literally as simple as like
downloading an app and then you can take
it and then there are local
brokers there who will uh trade you know
if you need the local currency or you
need something else you know they'll
take your bitcoin and give you
dollars or give you you know whatever
the local currency is
wow i had no idea so so crypto is more
popular there
it sounds like than it is here in
america um hard to know you know like
there
there's a lot of discretionary income
floating around in in america people
like to speculate
on stocks and all sorts of things so i
would say like the the speculation use
case is much higher in the u.s and in
the actual like
uh use out of necessity because it's
better than the alternative
is higher in other places one of the
biggest criticisms
we get of of we hear of crypto and even
like doing our little
nft sales there's a lot of people angry
or disappointed or
you know just in general unhappy with
the wastefulness of the crypto
the crypto market so yeah so what do you
like the econ the environmental impact
yeah you know i
i think this is just honestly i think
it's this is like fudding coming from
the big banks who are afraid about what
this means for
for their business and their control on
the economy
and you know when you look at bitcoin
yes
bitcoin and ethereum do expend a lot of
energy but so do
many other valuable things right like it
costs something because it's valuable
you know just like
uh even building batteries for electric
cars you know
has an environmental impact it's not
like everything is free of
so when you when you see these graphs
like we were looking at the other day it
goes
uh uh bitcoin produces the same amount
of energy
as let's say the almost as the whole
country argentina or something you know
what do you think like if you compared
it to other industries let's say like
batteries for electric cars or something
do you think how would that compare
you think it would be more or less or do
do we know that information
you know i think like so i i looked this
up a couple days ago it's still
like less than half of what is spent on
data centers around the world
um but i think it's more essential to be
totally fair
well is it you know i think a more fair
comparison would be what does it cost to
maintain the us dollar
as the world's reserve currency and you
know bitcoin is both a payment system
and a settlement system and when you
think about
all of the people and the computers
and the printing presses and the paper
and the trees that go into making the
money and
the you know it like cost more than a
penny to make a penny
yeah um imagine like all of the
resources that are going into
maintaining the system
uh you know in in terms of settlement
you know you have like the legal system
that's backing up the
chargebacks or you know disputes about
payments yeah
and you have the military that's backing
up the use of
the dollar globally and we saw that when
countries and historically have
attempted to go off of the dollar
standard and move to a gold standard
um you know start using gold to trade
for
oil instead of using dollars to trade
for oil there's u.s military
intervention there to enforce the use of
dollars
and they usually make something up some
other reason why they're sending in the
military but it's
almost always about uh they want to stop
using the dollar and they want to get on
some other standard
and so i think when you when you bake
all that into what is the cost of the
dollar um
you know bitcoin is is so small it's
such a fraction of that and
and when you think about like what is
the cost of a nation's currency failing
like argentina or venezuela you know it
completely destroys
the whole country and you know i think
having a stable currency that is not
manipulated by
a government is insanely valuable and it
might be the most valuable innovation
since the internet itself
do you think it's a problem that let me
ask you this is confusing i've got all
these ethereum in my wallet
so i can go let's say and sell ten
thousand where's the ten thousand
dollars coming from
yeah so there's someone on the other
side of that trade either either a
business is buying it from you directly
or
another trader so like on if you were to
sell it on kraken for example
uh we match buyers and sellers so it's
basically like ebay
where you have someone posting their
ether for sale and then there's someone
else on the other side who
decides to buy it at whatever price what
happens if
i guess that's how i guess i i'm just
ignorant on how
something basically like that works but
i guess if i'm trying to sell it
the market value is dictated by the
demand for people wanting to buy the
coin so i guess that's what
right yeah that's the plan it's just
just like the stock market yeah yeah
yeah
demand
a real quick um there's quite a few
updates on this
uh on this token it's now up to uh
4.9 we're up to all kids from a lot of
parties coming i mean jesse here
bidded uh 4.2 a while ago but now we
have a luca dvt
oh there's a new hey hey carlos
and ashley is still in there and then
somebody named matt uh castner
also just uh cast a bid so um this is
this is so excited it's like it's
exciting
it pushed it back like you said yeah now
it's
16 minutes i thought it went to 10 but
it looks like it's 20 whenever there's a
new bid
or maybe it adds 10 minutes or something
maybe yeah maybe right
so do you think that uh people in the
crypto space have a
have an obligation to invest some of
their
resources to environmental issues or do
you think the whole comparison is just
unfair to begin with yeah i think it's
an unfair
comparison to begin with i mean we don't
ask people to do that when they use when
they use dollars
or euros or you know pennies or whatever
so you know i think um
people that are already using crypto i
think are are contributing to
you know this global phenomenon in this
major social movement which is to take
back money from the government
you know and i think just like we have
the separation of church and state
we should have the separation of money
in state because
money has historically just been used
and abused by governments to
you know unfairly tax people or
propagate unnecessary wars and
and you know the financial system itself
prevents the regulations around that
prevent many people from even having
access to
to basic you know payment methods and
and basic ways to store value
so you know i think using bitcoin is is
making a social statement and
uh the more people that use it i think
the better off the world will be you
know the closer we'll get to being away
from
government-controlled currencies which
historically you know have all just
ended in disasters i mean look at
argentina venezuela zimbabwe
um you know even even the german
deutsche mark uh
you know there are so many examples
historically national currencies
only last a few decades before they end
up blowing up because governments end up
getting too greedy and inflating their
way out of problems
people lose confidence in the money it
destroys their economy
and um and then you know many countries
have fallen back to use the dollar
but i think now a lot of countries are
losing confidence even in the dollar
because the us government seems to be
willing to print unlimited amounts of
money so
um you know i think using bitcoin
yes it has a cost but so do lots of nice
things
so does running the internet you know so
do great
many things that that have super
positive impacts
on society and bitcoin is a peaceful way
to protest against
the existing system which is backed by
you know militaries and guns and wars
and things like that which are totally
anti-social when you so you got into
this space a long time ago like 10 years
ago are you did you
make that that fairytale investment
where you bought like a [ __ ] ton of
bitcoins and ethereum
at a super low uh valuation and now
you're sitting real nice
yeah i'm doing okay um yeah i
one of the biggest mistakes i made in my
life was um when bitcoin was a dollar
instead of buying a hundred thousand
bitcoin which would be worth like
five billion dollars today right um i
bought a hundred thousand dollars worth
of bitcoin mining equipment
oh yeah well that's yeah i mean
what i did the math and i was like okay
i'll make more bitcoin if i do the
mining but like
everyone had the same idea at the same
time i don't know if you're familiar
with how it works but it's sort of like
a raffle or it's like
the more people that are that are mining
at the same time like the smaller your
chances of
like getting bitcoin like the lower your
return is going to be
uh so i guess i had the same idea at the
same time and you guys were just talking
the other day about the
the trouble getting like gpus new the
new graphics cards to play video games
and stuff well this was like happening
back in 2011 as well
um like all these the the radeon 6990
was like the hottest
thing that you could mine bitcoin with
and um these were like insanely like
backordered and delayed
and so all the math that i had done was
just like out the window because
oh my god the order was like delayed by
like two months to get to me and then by
the time like i got everything it was
like bitcoin was like thirty dollars or
something
so how many so oh i so how many bitcoin
did you end up mining do you think
first the hundred thousand that you
could have got like what was yours yeah
i mind like
you miss out on almost like two thousand
two thousand coins or something
before which is a lot but it's not a
hundred thousand
yeah yeah yeah but i i didn't hold all
those coins all the way to the top you
know i had some other coins that i
bought too
but you know i think people think about
like oh i could have bought it at a
dollar and it'd be fifty thousand
dollars now but
you have to have like absolute hands of
steel
yeah old do that you know like diamond
hands baby
market would be like 20 you know like
you're not gonna hold from a dollar
to like even a hundred dollars like oh
my god i'm up 100
or you know whatever 10 000 for sure you
know i remember it was like a few years
ago where everyone thought
bitcoin like topped out at like 7 000
everyone's like oh it's over
i had friends who were like super
invested and they're like i'm out i'm
selling
you know the bubbles over so yeah you
need diamond hands for sure to hold
yeah but it's still early it's still
really good you really think it's still
early
i think so i think bitcoin is is is
going to be 500 000
i'll stop it within the next few years
huh yeah we'll live look at how much
money is going on
yeah easily okay easily we're gonna get
to a million dollars in bitcoin
if we don't have any you you would
recommend to get some
absolutely like at least dabble in it
you know i mean you guys are collecting
some ether i guess but you should have
some bitcoin too
like put you know one to ten percent of
your portfolio you know
i wouldn't say like go all in like don't
bet your rent money
don't bet your food money on bitcoin but
you know if you have a portfolio of
investments
you should absolutely have some bitcoin
in there here's another problem i have
with the crypto space or
a confusion rather than a problem
there's so
many types and there's more and more
every day it's like it just makes the
whole thing
feel a little bit silly when there's
like thousands of different cryptos
and new ones coming out and then
everyone's like oh this new crypto is
going to be it and this no this new
crypto is going to be it
it's like um
it's just too much there's too much uh
stuff but you're inventing currency just
like that i mean it just seems odd
yeah there's a very low barrier to entry
like anyone can
can create any new token anytime they
want i mean obviously you guys have have
made some tokens and the nft space is uh
you know blowing up but um you know i
think you should think about it
more like the stock market and there are
thousands of
thousands of stocks that you could buy
there are a lot of like
shitty stocks that you could buy um you
know some are like
um really strong like brand names you
know household names like
you have like the apple google facebook
you know all of these guys
and you know i think if just like with
the stock market if you don't really
know what you're doing if you're not
like some super
deep like wall street analyst like don't
buy
crazy stock number like 5900 you know
like stick to the top guys that you know
you know you have some personal
connection to the brand like
you know you're using apple devices
every day so you probably think like
apple's a pretty good company
um you know i would say like do that
with crypto as well you know like don't
pay attention to like all the new things
coming out constantly like
you know look at maybe like the top five
or just stick to like bitcoin and ether
if you want to be super safe i think
bitcoin and ether are super safe bets
um everything else yeah i mean it gets
more exotic and you get higher returns
with more risk
um but you know i wouldn't look at other
things like new things that are coming
out like every day is like where you're
going to put your life savings you know
maybe you put like
you know something small in there just
to like take a flier on it like buying a
lottery ticket you know but
um you know i would say like in terms of
like savings and long-term growth like
just stick to the things you know
do so big point is still a buy you heard
it from the crack
absolutely yeah interesting yeah i mean
you know i will i thought it was a
listen i
i thought it was the bubble was over a
few years ago when i was at like seven
thousand i was like look at these people
losing all their money
it sounds like sixty thousand dollars
now so what the i don't know [ __ ]
apparently
you got diamond hands what's the longest
you've held bitcoin for
years like 10 years it's something
you've held for 10 years
yeah well yeah i've sold some over time
yeah yeah you know but
yeah i mean yeah i have some some
bitcoin from how many coins you got
oh i can't say okay you know i tried you
guys the other day by the way you know
that would be like that obviously i have
to say what i have and then i have
people showing up in my house
i understand i just wanted to ask i i
thought i'd give it a shot
[Laughter]
well that was you know i love learning
about this stuff because i
am frankly quite ignorant on all this
yeah
it's really interesting i feel so far
from understanding it but this was
really good thank you for
all the information you got me wanting
to sell all my everything and just go
bitcoin you should be selling yeah your
kidneys and
kidneys [ __ ] it whatever i've got
whatever i think i
i don't know if you guys i i think i saw
you guys have like a rolls-royce
i don't know if you bought that for cash
but i think
you should okay because i i bought some
stuff people bitcoiners do this all the
time
where they'll buy something and then
they'll look back like oh i bought
you know i bought it i bought a tesla a
few years ago
for cash and the tesla now
you know it's like a three million
dollar uh car
it just held on if i just bought bitcoin
instead or like you know reminds me of
uh
that's crazy reminds me of the end of
schindler's list
this ring could have saved three lives
that's how you feel every day exactly
yeah sell everything
it's only regret in selling bitcoin so i
don't recommend it
yeah i was i was going to dump all my
ethereum do you think i should hold
let's see
i was telling him that we should hold it
i would hold i mean if you don't have
something else to do with the cash
don't sell unless you have like a better
investment to make because your dollars
sitting in your bank account are just
getting inflated away
to nothing so you know if you're going
to sell ether buy bitcoin with it don't
just like sit on cash
oh you think bitcoin is the better
investment right now
i don't know i wouldn't say that i think
they're both super promising
i think the ecosystem around ethereum is
is growing faster there's also just some
some technical reasons why ethereum
might be
increasing in value over time you know
maybe more rapidly
one i think is that um so there's this
process right now of migrating from
the ethereum one blockchain to the
ethereum two blockchain
and to do that you basically need to
burn your coins on ethereum one and then
you get
coins on this other ethereum two chain
um
but this migration period is going to
last potentially a few years
and so but in the process of doing this
anyway you get some some amount of
interest or something while while the
migration is happening but
a lot of people are burning their ether
1 to get over to ether 2
which is still years away but after you
burn it you can't like undo this
so the supply available supply of
ethereum
is shrinking right now and so i think
that's taking some
cell pressure off of the market so i
think the price is
maybe more likely to come up and then
this eventual upgrade of ethereum
is going to move it to a a proof
proof-of-stake
system which means like it's not going
to rely on like mining the way that
bitcoin does
um it'll basically be like a voting type
of system where you
the amount of ether that you hold will
represent like your number of votes for
the system
so um sort of like a share based voting
thing like you have in like what do you
vote on
uh you vote on like protocol changes and
you can you also will vote on
um like in the way that bitcoin does the
mining
basically the miners are sort of
authenticating the transactions
so that's called like a proof of work
system where you're like
crunching numbers to to process
transactions um the proof of stake
system
where it's like you're voting with your
share of ownership uh
you will be voting on like the validity
of transactions basically
like you know is a transaction authentic
um
is it legit or someone trying to spend
the same coins twice things like that i
mean it's basically the same stuff that
you're doing bitcoin mining but
it's not an automated uh it's an
automated
program i get that it'll be automated
yeah i mean conceivably you could make
it not automated
but what can i do i have a soft brain
well one thing you don't need to
understand unfortunately i mean like you
know you like
we don't understand how like the credit
card networks work behind the scenes or
how the internet oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like yeah jesse i
i've heard that because i was reading up
about all this stuff that the
proof-of-stake thing
supposedly uh solves a lot of the
environmental issues right doesn't it
it uses way less power to do it that way
for sure
yeah that's definitely one of the
arguments for the proof of mistake is
that you don't have to have
these computers turning away all the
time how is your
new coins generated once you remove that
uh so there's there's still there could
be depends on the protocol but there
could still be a schedule of just
releasing new coins into the system
uh the the people who are participating
in the voting
uh of the proof-of-stake system
so if you have a computer participate in
that or only the big
the big anyone with ether so it's like a
dragon personal share kind of thing
so you know whether you have one show or
a million shares that sounds cool i mean
then then it's like a stock dividend
type of thing right exactly yeah oh
interesting
yeah you only get paid the dividend if
you're participating in in the votes
we like that i've got 15 ethereum let's
[ __ ] go where's my dividend
coming up well if you stake it now and
you burn it
you can start getting getting some
dividends on your
this is some high level [ __ ] you're
talking about burning my digital coins
getting dividends on ethereum too i'm in
the [ __ ] future
jesus one other thing that people like
about the proof of stake
is that there's some kind of far out
like future threat
that um governments eventually like
get so upset with bitcoin that they go
and try to confiscate all of the mining
equipment out there
and you couldn't do that with a proof of
stake system interesting
since there aren't there aren't like
physical minors you know to to take
just like a software they'll have to pry
my gtx
from my cold dead hands
if you're mining bitcoin with the gpus
at this point you're probably
wasting money oh really what do you mind
yeah yeah you can't
it's not it's not going to be productive
there are specialized chips now
for mining bitcoin wow called asics
um so what are the [ __ ] graphics
cards why can't i
i've been waiting like three months from
our goddamn podcast computer we just
want to it's it's ridiculous
there are other tokens that you can mine
with the gps
so yeah people are getting these to like
mine all the hot new
crazy coins nice they're coming out
well jesse it's been a really uh
educational really interesting
conversation
i appreciate it you guys uh oh there's
one minute
oh no there's 11 minutes left maybe yeah
there was just a bid that
popped it up to 7.5
it just jumped quite a bit oh i don't
see that on my computer yet you might
want to refresh
because yeah carlos is impressed
wow oh [ __ ] i wasn't updated so with
every bit it adds time
it adds 10 or 20 minutes it adds 10
minutes i believe
wow look it up did you follow the
big connect stuff what did you think
about the big connect stuff
did you know that was a scam from the
beginning for sure
like there's so many of these ponzis in
bitcoin like i think people are kind of
like
um aware of them now but i mean you
still see it happening occasionally
but yeah it was like a straight up ponzi
from the beginning i mean anything
promising like you know 50 rewards a
week or something
or returns a week is just like obviously
a scam and it blows my mind that people
still
fall for this stuff but you know i mean
people are still following
falling for the nigerian prince emails
as well right program
yeah like some demographic that just
like buys into it yeah
um carlos yeah well carlos did you what
was your thoughts on big connect i know
carlos
did you learn your lesson or what's your
stance on crypto carlos
he still loves it he really loves it
wow oh my god
oh wow okay well he carlos disagrees
with you uh
that's okay has anyone seen that guy is
he inviting he's in i think he's in yeah
he's a nightmare
big time all right jesse i'm going to
let you go thanks for taking the time
we appreciate you that was great yeah
god bless absolutely
unleash the kraken right that's what
they say oh don't
do we want the kraken on unleashed or no
you want to unleash it for sure yeah
it's a protector
okay let's get that cracking out there
thank you jesse all right thanks guys
have a good one thanks take care
did we learn something i think so i
think so oh wow the
bit so guys the bid is up to eight
points i mean i learned a lot about
bitcoin it's exciting
whoa it's going crazy i think you know i
think he makes a valid point
about the environmental impact that too
it does make sense to me because like
you said there's a cost to everything
precious that's not analyzed in the same
way like when you see these charts it's
like well bitcoin
produces the same amount of energy as
the country of argentina it's like well
let's get every industry on there and
see because
it's kind of misleading just to see it
out of
but also learning about the benefits in
countries where the currency is not
stable was really interesting
so he's saying where the currency is so
unstable you put your money into the
into the crypto it holds the value
instead of losing it
where before you know otherwise you
wouldn't have access
to other currency to is that is that
what he means
yeah because when these countries are
experiencing hyperinflation which he did
make the point
um that in a lot of those examples of
countries that are experiencing
hyperinflation that's happening because
of the united states
sanctioning them or doing other types of
economic warfare
in order to uh to get them to fall in
line and so
um yeah i mean money in the financial
global financial system it's it's used
as a tool to uh
control people um in a in a variety of
ways
what what i what i do i i mean
he knows a lot more about this stuff
than me but you know he brings up the
fact
that all of these countries um when they
try and move away from
you know the dollar the the united
states cracks down on them and
you know militarily intervenes and stuff
and that i think that is a
important point um i do have a fear
that there is a big crackdown on all of
this crypto stuff
coming you mean from governmental body
yeah yeah i felt that too because
well they started taxing it recently
there's like all these rules and
regulations now where before i think for
a long time was like wild west just like
right thank you and i think the reality
is is that the banks and the big
financial institutions are very
threatened by this
and um i don't they're not they're not
going to go silently they're they're
going to go down fighting
you know what i mean sure yeah those are
like the most powerful forces you know
and
that's why you know i i don't i'm i have
no idea what's gonna happen but
to think that it's just gonna coast its
way into replacing
the dollar in the world is um you know
there's not
it's going to be more complicated than
that well that and i don't think he was
even necessarily saying that it's
that's just adding to his point but um
but yeah i'm curious to see
you know how it's all going to play out
over there the blockchain the blockchain
2
sounds a lot sounds like it'd make a lot
more sense
so that's that's cool what surprised me
is he according to him he says there's
people in argentina who are selling
[ __ ] loaves of bread who you can pay
with
with crypto i get it i mean everyone's
got a phone
no i get it too i just didn't know it
was so you were already there
no daddy that was really interesting huh
the world is not anymore the way it used
to be carlos was so ahead of him
carlos knows someone just sent me this
on discord
uh new york times did a write up on
david dobrik whoa
losing fans and subs and stuff so new
york times
yeah damn um
this is crazy do we do we make the gray
lady what does that mean that's like the
nickname
the gray lady yeah i don't know why they
call it i don't know did she mention
did she mention us let's see probably
not that'd be kind of wild
i started to read it but then a paywall
came up son
[Music]
i don't need to be mentioned but let's
see i'm not taking credit for anything
nope no mention of me [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] them [ __ ] the new york times [ __ ]
great lady
fake news yo this is pretty epic guys
we're at
we're at 8.3 coins here i'm not leaving
until this auction is done you mark my
[ __ ] words i'll be our all goddamn
night
i wonder if at a certain point maybe we
should lower that extension time from 10
minutes to just
a couple minutes not actually no you
want it to just
well can you do that while the bid's
going on that seems crooked
i i don't know they're in the final leg
you're going to change the rules up on
them now
i see i see what you're saying what am i
going to do
all right we've got actually a lot of
other great stuff to do we're gonna keep
an eye on this coin as the bidding
unfolds
there's a lot of interested parties
though there's like at least four
five six people
who are who are bidding now wow that's
awesome
oh so so the
okay back to the james charles thing
this is something a lot of people are
saying
is that this james charles video i
called out in the very beginning they
had like pewdiepie and corpse and dream
and all this [ __ ]
was filmed before the controversy
happened
but like so what i mean
you know what i mean it's the majority
of his fans don't know that who are
watching
they just you know what i mean well i
mean it it makes a difference for
um the call whatever culpability you
wanted to assign to the people that are
collaborating with them
if they did it before don't you think
latest news came out sure
sure sure but yeah i agree it's not like
they knowingly collab but don't you
think that
they should it's a little difficult
shouldn't there be a conversation about
like
it's a little difficult because how
how would you go about it like as let's
say
one of these people i would i i
personally would say i don't want
you're gonna have to edit me out because
like after a huge controversy scandal
happens the majority of james fans
don't know what happened what happened
or when this video was recorded
so someone like dream or corpse husband
coming in and doing this big collab with
him
essentially them normalizing james
charles and saying this is an okay
person do yeah associated which is the
same thing happened with woody allen
i feel like also what's scary about it
is that he
learns that he can get away with it so
he's just gonna keep doing things that
he can get away with dude he's been
caught so many times doing this and he
never saw he literally said in his
apology
i'm not gonna stop i'll just check their
id right like you can't fake an id or
or like he's even gonna ask let's be
honest
you know that is so true abe says yeah
they could have made it they could have
made a public statement about it none of
them said
anything so i'm assuming i'm just gonna
assume they don't know
but or they just want to avoid drama
they just want to keep their
if they wanted to avoid drama they
shouldn't have [ __ ] they should have
told them to cut them out of the video
it's not the corpse breath
it reminds me of being at the doctor i
don't know to me
to me it seems it was like okay i i
it's possible they don't know okay so
i'm not it's not like i'm going after
them i'm just saying like there needs to
be a point
where people need to understand that
you're co-signing a predator
and sending your fans potentially to be
you know groomed and
and and preyed upon by him yeah
i mean he's the dude is sick anyway up
to nine let's go jesse
crypto boycott dude jessie's dude that
guy's a legend bro
you know he's the top bid right now look
at that dude you know
like everybody wish they were like this
guy jesse who was like
he's like yo bitcoin was one dollar and
i was going to invest
i was ready to invest a hundred thousand
dollars in it either
either just buying coins or trying to
mine it or whatever but
i had i had a um i was gonna say friend
he wasn't really a friend just a guy i
knew an acquaintance or whatever
that was super into this god i mean it
was like 2008 or nine or something like
this
and i thought he was just so stupid i
remember he was like so excited he like
bought a pizza once for like he did
because there was some
yeah some pizza place was like accepting
it
which is what now like a billion dollars
yeah that pizza would be worth like a
billion dollars because it was like
the bitcoins were worth like 0.001
at the time like just absolutely nothing
and he had like
a ton of them maybe not that low but you
know him still
no he's a friend of a friend somewhere
yeah i remember being at parties with
him and he was one of those guys that's
just like prattling on about krypto and
you're like i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about man but have fun
with that
we should have listened to listen we
should have listened yeah
i love pizza and i love people papa's
counting those bitcoins right now
okay we got some good [ __ ] as this
unfolds um let's start with our favorite
preacher
daddy when did you go bold by the way
that knew
what dan spinball like six months ago
yeah i guess you always wear a hat
i don't know well we're a hat kind of
show but
yeah did you just you're like you know
what what was your thought process you
just said let's just get it over with
kind of yeah exactly like my hair is
going and so i said [ __ ] it and probably
look better
just shave so right and it was yeah i
mean it was a while ago it was like
because it was i remember it was still
really hot and it was during lockdown so
you couldn't go get a haircut
and i was just like you know what [ __ ]
it let me ask you this do you have to
sunscreen your dome
no no but i usually do wear a hat so i
don't know right
because you're a good man
it suits you i mean yeah you look good
as soon as i did it i was like i should
have done this years ago
i'm glad solatika i mean look
baldi it's a look bro that's a vibe the
dome
look at picard he's an icon bro card's
like not my heroes man
bruce willis is a vibe it's a rock
and i look just like those guys
all right should mail up that dome
i'm going the wrong way to mail you the
dump because i got to get to like 200
pounds but we'll get there
and we'll get that all right our
favorite preacher our semen obsessed
homophobic creature yeah people like
singular cancer we keep there's so many
great clips of this guy they keep coming
up
well now that we've been talking about
on the show people have been uh sending
them in i think this one was uh
somebody sent it to us so now he's going
on
about butt holes shooting up flames
what oh you haven't seen the cielo no
yeah so last week we watched a video of
him talking about how he thinks
starbucks puts
semen in their caf coffee and that's why
it tastes so good right
because he says you know semen is just
another type of meal
semen is is another kind of milk
so now he go now he has a whole sermon
about butthole
let's enjoy
god's going to put a cancer oh zach
snyder shout out
god's going to put her zack snyder shot
this that's cool
the aspect ratio got it good one
[Applause]
in the butthole of every sodomite every
sodomite
butthole will get cancer in the butthole
it'll burn and burn and burn they won't
be able to sit down
because of the burning in their butthole
he can't sit down
he's got a burning in his butt
coming out of his butthole he's so upset
he can't have any sex he's so upset he
just
this guy would be such a good gay you
would be at like the center of a gay
orgy just loving every minute of it you
know what i mean
every hole filled and plugged and just
seeming and
tastes good exactly it's just such a
shame this guy's depriving himself of
what could be the best life
god's gonna have a flame coming out of
your butthole you're going to have a
flame coming out of your butthole
if you thought that aids was bad you
ain't seen
nothing yet until you see the flaming
butthole
your butthole will be flaming and you
will not be able to sit down
until you have a flame coming out of
your butthole and there'll be people
walking around all over america
with flames coming out of their butthole
i have a feeling if that's the case
he's got a talent for talking about
buttholes
he's passionate about it yeah he is very
passionate about bundles and demons
yeah i have a feeling if if there's some
kind of rapture where flames come out
the butthole
he's gonna have the biggest flame of all
this guy's taken
this guy's taking some things up there
i'm sure of it
everyone who takes it up the rear
everyone who everyone
injected in his butthole when that penis
comes out
the flame will start burning because
ain't nobody gonna stick no penis
in that flame that flame would be an
eternal flame coming out of the butthole
of every side of that thing coming out
of the butthole flame coming out of your
butt that man pulls that penis out of
you
a flame is going to come out and nobody
will ever stick a penis in your butthole
again
because it will be you ain't seen
nothing
till you see the flame coming out of td
jake's butt
you need jakes he's he's getting awfully
sweet
he's getting real specific who's teeny
jake
but isn't teeny make you think of like a
child yeah
oh man oh jake paul
like why did you why she teeny jake bro
the flame coming out of teeny jake's
butt
bruh i don't like that
lightning bug got a flame coming out of
his butt at all
he's shooting out of their behinds
you're gonna see the power of god
playing with fires gonna come out that
butthole
wow that's a lot it was a lot
i got a piece really bad i'm going to uh
be right back
so bad can we watch something
yeah here's a video of me mispronouncing
words for 11 minutes gotta have to pee
so bad
you guys saw that this i don't think
we're gonna watch the whole thing but i
can roll it while i go pee
okay perfect dispatch
whatever i you know what i understand i
said it wrong and i don't even
i don't even care what the real one is
to spot you
what is it what just tell me what it is
don't laugh at me
despacito
flash cut you look bomb today i'm just
looking at the camera you look all the
arc and like
you look like a uh sliving slithender
slip
slip and splittender
i mean i know about intermittent fasting
but zack goes i've lost eight weights
l eight eight god what is wrong with me
and then of course tenacious x who
passed away
uh who said smoking a fat okay i don't
know it's
one but it is definitely not tenacious
this is serious you remember when george
washington heard that 911
that the airplanes hit the world trade
center remember that and he just sat
there
for like 10 minutes
that's how i was looking out this window
[Laughter]
because i just sat down and i was
watching it
you know do you know that scene it's
famous from what yeah when
when george w wait did i say washington
slow down george bush
you guys might need like a dump truck of
shungite
i need to deliver this suge knight the
should knight
all right you guys had enough there's
there's one part of
the time that's the best part which one
there's a part where um
let's see let me see 11 minutes have i
really
[ __ ] up that much well it's i mean
almost
what we're going on four years with
podcasts we got a new bed we're nearing
10 man y'all are
you all big
um oh
we had some really interesting
uh tick tock finds this past week yeah
as you know we're obsessed with
how do you say his name that was pretty
close
so we found what i believe to be is the
let's say white i don't know white
version of
muhammad says
oh
anyway watch this one i saw this one on
my feed
the beauty of tik tok
[Music]
so hit me with a classic
no you're living okay joke god made her
man-made chemical do you gonna trust
listen up
god where did this guy come from on
[Laughter]
hey
it he said i learned something new today
when women have menopause
men do too oh what how did you get i
don't know
i we listened to it like 20 times
yesterday i wasn't able to understand it
for some reason it just clicked what
he's saying right now
user 876619307551 mikey us that's his
name
not later got me there which one do you
try
blue you gotta
so i want to get these two in a room and
just listen
to the conversation that takes place i
think zach's prepared a little bit of uh
oh you've put a little bit of banjo
style
situation listen up there
ain't no joke god made her man-made
chemical do you all right
you you prepared something for us oh we
just crushed ten shout out to jesse
jesse the legend kraken
the crack boy we love jesse
not high on crack he's high on
crypto i don't know listen i'm trying
over here
go ahead zach what do you got for us
[Music]
but boy bad boy what you gonna do god
made her
wake up
you're buying who you gonna trust
god made herb
[Music]
blue you gonna trust god made herbs
get them all going at once
[Music]
yes
i don't know ten yeah we passed ten
thanks to the kraken
wow
[Music]
so that's my boy you guys want to take
you see what um mo
oh i found another great tick tock guy
like white claw gabe
dude this guy's awesome another one that
showed up on my home page
so white clock gabe i don't he seems to
be
of some kind of asian descent
hate [ __ ] so he had a statement about
asian hate i'm terrorizing this
asian hate [ __ ] man [ __ ] [ __ ] racism man
i'm proud of me myself i'm proud i'm
proud to be asian
i contribute a lot man i could we all
contribute a lot in this country [ __ ]
man [ __ ] racism man [ __ ] i stand for
myself i'm happy with myself
[ __ ] [ __ ] racism man [ __ ]
i don't know if it's the best first one
to show because it needs some context
but i agree i think that's a good
message
this is the first one i saw and this is
kind of the iconic white claw game
it it's yeah fried chicken wednesday
baby yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite
nights
because of fried chicken yeah [ __ ]
wednesday night baby
[ __ ] fried chicken yep fried chicken
wednesday
fried chicken wednesday who deserves
fried chicken me
i deserve fried chicken [ __ ]
wednesday right wednesday night
fried chicken yeah closer to the weekend
thursday
and then friday here comes the weekend
[ __ ] [ __ ] wednesday night fried
chicken wednesday baby
who deserves fried chicken me who
deserves fried chicken me
love fried chicken chicken wednesday
baby [ __ ] fried chicken wednesday
wait did it start over and it's still
going fried chicken
so this boy this dude's called white
club gabe because he
on the weekends he drinks tons of white
cloth huh which is like what is like a
flavored beer or something kind of thing
oh it's alcohol or
yeah seltzer i have not been in the
alcohol game
since all these like white claw this
stuff came out you know back in college
when i was drinking i don't really drink
it all
it was just there was none of these fun
spirits and
bubbly [ __ ] budweiser bubbly [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're really good but the problem is
they sneak up on you
like i think i would have liked it a lot
you you have a
you have a lot of them quite close you
realize you don't realize how drunk
you're getting you
you realize you had five and you're like
oh [ __ ] okay
so let's see here here let's see what
yeah
finally
oh oh we can't listen to that okay what
are you doing you never put music in
your videos
but yeah here he just posted this right
now i gotta go to the studio and make
some money
[ __ ] i'm bawling i'm balling baby yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
i gotta support i gotta support all
these friends
to take care for the rib eyes and [ __ ]
man [ __ ]
[ __ ] friday baby they have barbecue
the white car
we're not going to see you there's no
[ __ ] sushi night today
[ __ ] man i gotta go to the studios
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i don't know when it's but yeah he's
awesome i love gabe yeah he's such a lot
of my favorite knights
he [ __ ] loves his white claw here
let's watch this one
to all the people who think you're tough
[ __ ] you you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] man [ __ ] he think you
he's sick you're tough guess what you're
a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
that's a good stomach chicken fried
chicken wednesday
but [ __ ] man this is me this is
this is me when eela says we can't order
pizza
i deserve pizza [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] fried chicken
yeah he's like he's like
i couldn't tell if he was like doing a
character or not but i went all the way
back i've done a lot of research on this
guy
i've done he definitely he does he seems
to have
you know i i don't i don't know
but but it's definitely not in character
i'll say that
and if you go back long enough he's not
cursing either because i thought maybe
he's got like
some kind of compulsion to curse but if
you go back
you see the chat's asking if he has
tourette's no he doesn't have tourette's
for sure
okay
well well you it wouldn't look like that
oh what do you mean well i don't see any
other ticks
because usually if your tourette's is
that bad where you're scr you have to be
screaming obscenities he'd be like you'd
be seeing other
i see you'll be seeing other symptoms of
tourette's but that's not to say that
there's not some kind of compulsion
that would make you want to curse like
that repeatedly but if you go back
but he was white he was always white
claw gay which i find interesting but
but he used to not curse like that
i love it yeah white clothes everywhere
ye
white claw white cloth everywhere three
rows in the back
white clothes everywhere why cause
everything
so so is it he kind of like
i think he had one where he was cursing
a bunch and it took off and so i think
do you think he's playing it up [ __ ]
fried chicken
yeah oh my god
still here that the [ __ ] van
[ __ ] man four days in a row the [ __ ]
van is here
come on i i don't have
i don't i don't have all day i don't
have oh yeah i don't have all my life to
have this bad move out of my
property come on [ __ ] so maybe i'm wrong
here's to be on the street
i can't [ __ ] believe it oh no
[Applause]
[ __ ] seconds i don't [ __ ] believe
it
they let that go no timeouts for the
rares come on
man what the [ __ ] anyway he's the best
i love them so the uh the auction's down
to two and a half minutes
oh jesse's currently uh at the top it
hasn't updated at 10.1 we have uh
we have here two minutes left we've got
the cracking up top at 10.1 folks 10.1
one of the one of the two guys we spoke
to last week
hey you asked him how much uh you
thought the gold coin would go for you
he said 10.
prophetic gun what's going twice we got
nobody out here with deep pockets nobody
out here with deep pockets
and we are coming carlos carlos are you
out there
are you saying 10 ethereum for that
isn't that's not deep pockets oh that's
what
i
do no this is that is deep
i think he's saying we've reached us
deeper
where's the deeper anyway he talk i love
when he talks about food heroes
it's [ __ ] saint patrick's day yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sad all right wake up we love
you
i deserve fried chickens [ __ ] wins
that's the best i deserve fried chicken
i love the idea of deserving it
um yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite
nights okay you guys ready for this one
this girl's a phenomenon on tick tock
she's always on my homepage
this has 1.2 million likes probably
means what god i don't know 10 million
views or something so she has a very
unique style of fighting here i'll watch
she farts she rubs her hand
did you see that yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's 4.2 million views what
[Music]
she always farts on i cannot believe
that
you
oh somebody just bid at the last week we
had someone come in at the last minute
right now coming in at the very last
minute we've got
we've got 0f287e coming in at the last
minute with a 10.6
wow see and that bumps it back up to 10
that's why i'm wondering if we should no
10 minutes is good i thought 20 was a
lot
okay well we can't change it now
[Music]
you can't change the rules of the
[ __ ] last quarter of the game what
are you crazy
it seems so anti-climactic
thousand dollars no but it's like isn't
it like
options yeah that's what i was
yeah i thought we were in the final 30
seconds there was ready to do a
countdown
yeah this is amazing though thank you
for watching
this is crazy dude it's at 20 000 for
this
i am so excited carlos is
jacked the person that's in this bidding
war is anonymous too yeah
they're just unnamed and they they have
no other nfts
do we know who this person is are they
associated with our discord or anything
like that
no it's just there's no way to know it's
literally unnamed if you click on it
is it carlos do you think maybe
who is unnamed that's so intriguing here
he is
um
seven days a week what was he gonna say
well we were talking about the the girl
that farts oh yeah
i think a lot of guys would pay money
for this kind of experience i think
like look at the views it says 7.6
million wow
what you think you're cool cause you
have a leather jacket
oh my god zach does this turn you on
no you don't like hunky it looks
it looks painful you don't like how she
would you let a girl fart in your face
like this though
oh she took him out oh my god
i'm impressed treat
just find out that they're into this and
then post a tick tock of it
like well let me find the earliest
example because i've been seeing these
on my feed for like
what feels like 12 million views that's
so loud it's so
good okay so here she hasn't been at it
for very long it seems like they're
relatively normal let's see when's the
earliest example of the fart attack
here it is 1.9 million fart attack
when someone talks to me before i've had
my coffee
did she perform a farting attack i'm
wondering back then
oh the ass flap okay
burning in their butthole zach would you
let a girl fart on your face
no come on i mean come on
yeah what do you mean come on it's just
a little a little bit too far
zach i learned something so funny about
you recently that i can't tell
really yeah i don't think you were there
he told us after that
it was the funniest thing ever i'll tell
you after this
so there you go that's the first thing
that's the first no fart attack
dude this girl can make a lot of money
performing this service
burning in their butthole
what is this ass attack i've never heard
of this
and this time she was like under the
underwear too so you know that's a
stinky
nice little slab what is that one that
one was
interesting too i'm gonna come
oh jeez
[Music]
oh dude no way
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
this is dude tick tock is off the rails
i will continually say it's my favorite
platform how much time we got back now
on the coin
down to um about five minutes all right
cracking you let this guy show you up
this anonymous guy 0f287e this anonymous
guy's coming for the kraken
look at them come for you carlos would
like to talk to you about this
investment opportunity
stephen crowder's a piece of [ __ ] can i
even watch that without getting like my
video removed i don't know man it's
pretty bad
stephen crowd i want to watch it so bad
but i feel like i'll get our
our whole video that's not
super racist like apparently in the new
stimulus there was like a
certain amount of like it's like six
billion dollars set aside for black
farmers or not just
black farmers but like uh no i think
that is
okay so black farmers i thought it was
other like minority groups as well
he goes oh what's like are there really
any black farmers like you got people
lining up
dude i can't even dude i can't even
imitate it
yeah it's way worse than that
thoughts on this
wait wait what
what
yes i don't get that one so much
i've seen this trend quite a bit tonight
you have
yeah on tick tock where they they like
yank all the hair out of you
[Music]
they just straight yank it out
this doesn't seem to be about hair no it
is about hair
yeah it's white yeah it's wax i don't
know why it is though yeah
why don't you just fart in his face and
get over with him
well there was something over his
eyebrows i think oh
cause i was wondering that too
[Music]
i don't know it is it is odd no there's
no hair coming out i think you're right
he's fully shaped
yeah maybe it's just the pores like
cleaning the pores
that's about the hair no trust me no
hair came out there you think this just
well then maybe you're right because why
are they popping balloons on yeah
this is not about some kind of fetish eh
oh jessie bit again the kraken's back
uh oh oh the kraken came back
this anonymous this anonymous guy i
don't know that he can step to the crowd
dude the crack is ready this guy's got
bitcoining
mining [ __ ] from back in the day you
cannot step to the crack
holy [ __ ] guacamole wow
shout out to the crack okay i think
you're right man i think this
this isn't a barber this is like a
dominatrix yes
[Music]
what is there's one there's a there's
like
you would see his reaction when the hair
gets removed
there's other people saying clearing and
cleaning pores
yeah this skin looks kind of [ __ ] up
from this
because like i feel like that cannot be
good for the skin
like i know what face mask but what the
hell is this what's with that
and why is he popping balloons on his
face
i'm telling you just fart on his face
bring that girl out
get it done with
um
oh you seen this either did you know the
pokemons are evil
what's your favorite favorite crazy
christian video satanic [ __ ] so
so pokemon is a game that teaches
children how to enter into the world of
witchcraft how to cast spells
how to use psychic phenomena how to put
work supernatural powers against their
enemies
how to fantasy role play pokemon world
in the world of the demonic
of the satanic but we might not take it
quite
seriously i assure you that demons take
it quite seriously
satan takes it quite seriously your
children knew
the devil jigglypuff you satanic little
[ __ ]
so i've been so back in the day oh we
got speaker issues
it's always tick tock man back in the
day tick tock is just like corrupts our
[ __ ] whole setup it's crazy when um
when pokemon was really popular when i
went on like game boy stuff when
everyone was playing my age
there was a couple of kids at the school
always including kids i knew
whose parents wouldn't let him play
pokemon because they thought it was
satanic
swear to god that was like a common
thing
do you guys know anyone that wasn't
allowed to play pokemon because it was
satanic i've never heard anything
satanic it's [ __ ] pokemon
yeah and he was like bullied i feel so
bad for that kid i remember
because he wasn't allowed see that's
what happens you know what i mean you're
trying to like save his soul and he just
gets up [ __ ] blowing
grows up and then becomes a crap a meth
head anyway because he's had such a
shitty childhood
you know right that's wild
god i'm telling you man there ain't
nothing like a brain on jesus
people like simon
i mean pokemon is a japanese game so
like i mean japanese people aren't
really even christian are they the
pokemon cards got banned at my
elementary school
for being satanic i don't know uh well
they got banned at my
uh it was middle school and it wasn't
for being satanic it was because um
there were constant fights happening
over them yeah
you know when our walls were yo-yos
really popular when you guys were kids
there was a there was a yo-yo phase when
i was in middle school yeah
wow so there was there's a lot of
stealing yo-yos and
yeah what's the predominant religion in
japan is it buddhism
uh buddhism or it's called shinto is the
like traditional
folk religion of japan because like
christianity is not even
really a thing there barely uh there is
a
there is a significant christian
minority in japan actually
i mean those christians have the best
[ __ ] salesmen
like it's crazy how they get around
the missionaries i see a lot of people
in the chat are saying they
they're familiar with this like the
demonic pokemon
yeah it was a big deal that's crazy it
wasn't like a small time thing
i don't know i mean i get i don't know
if this i don't think that's the thing
in israel
the most parents would tell you is like
because you they want you to play
outside so they don't want you to
have that same weird voodoo christian
same demon [ __ ] that christianity
has
right jesus yes jesus is your source
yeah that's crazy yo tell me this are
there
yes shinto and buddhism so it's like
dude the root of japanese
of mainstream japanese culture isn't it
harry potter some kids
oh yeah can i watch harry potter oh my
god
that's literally witchcraft hello but it
was one time
a movie hello there was one time uh
it was in sixth grade i was wearing a
metallica t-shirt
and there was a teacher there they told
me i was gonna go to hell
if i continue to listen to metallica
metallica
i guess because they have like the
skeletons and [ __ ] right right
i'm like wow okay see you there
you know what was the craziest thing a
teacher told me that [ __ ] me up for
kind of like
all throughout my early adulthood i had
this vivid memory
it was so [ __ ] up it was in like
seventh or eighth grade middle school
sex education okay okay
and she said she's she's like a
middle-aged woman
she says i want to tell you class all
something
women do not enjoy sex
she says women do not get pleasure from
sex
only men get pleasure from sex and we do
it
to have babies but women do it does not
feel good
she told the whole class that and it
[ __ ]
it really [ __ ] me up that is wild
because i was like whoa that's not like
then like i i was like
yeah what well that makes sense i don't
want to do that
yeah i'm assuming it was fun for
everybody
and um that was probably the most [ __ ]
up thing a teacher ever told me
damn what about you guys i just
um i just remembered the first time i
read harry potter it was like
the first time i read a book i actually
cared about oh
we got a new offer sorry sorry to cut
you off there we got a 14
the crack just got out kraken we're up
to 14. wow this is incredible this is
incredible moment
folks from outlier he was a previous
bidder i don't know who he is let's
snoop on him a little bit
no no activity wow nothing in his wallet
another he says call me bear barrison
that's his info okay do we know anything
about this guy abe have you spoken to
him
no i haven't gotten anything from him
interesting sorry you'll go ahead
um i just it's just so silly like i was
just saying as a kid harry potter was my
favorite
book the first time i enjoyed reading a
book
harry potter was a great experience for
me it was like the first time i read a
book in like a day well too bad you're
going to hell
[Laughter]
you guys remember any crazy [ __ ]
teachers told you
yes definitely go ahead i had a i had a
teacher
that told me that demons are gonna lock
my soul in a box
and shoot flaming arrows at it and help
what'd you do
and um
yeah so there was this arabic school in
our hometown where i only went for like
a month
and obviously that's why it wasn't
supposed to be like a religious school
but they took some liberties
and there was like some like extremist
teachers that were like anything you did
was a sin and uh yeah i think it was
just for for talking back once they told
me that
damn no talk back at your [ __ ] that
was a brutal punishment for talking back
yeah yeah my my cousin didn't scare you
how did you respond to that i always
scared the [ __ ] out of me i was a very
like crush
probably work did the trick right yeah i
already felt like i didn't fit in there
so i know it was really weird but my uh
my cousin tim went there for years and
he said that the nickname for that
he's a he's a shaq which is like a
muslim version of a priest
they used to call him j lo because for
some reason the super religious guy had
these
pants he wore that had j.lo on it so
jennifer lopez just a picture of her no
no it was like it was like uh
like uh bedazzled like the words the
letters j-lo
oh they were like that which female
super funny because he was super
religious
yeah that's pretty good yeah my cousin
i'm sorry i'm not trying to keep talking
but my cousin ultimately got kicked out
of the school for saying [ __ ] you jlo
to that guy oh he's going to hell yeah
sorry buddy i had a teacher uh
they used to call me fat
that's not cool how did you respond to
that
i just sat there i was so embarrassed i
didn't know how to react how old were
you
i was fifth grade so what is that fifth
grade they call you fat
that's insane did you tell your parents
awful
of course ended up getting the girl
fired [ __ ] her oh yeah of course
yeah like seriously just totally
traumatized me what did she say
she was she was go wow zack you're
looking big today
who says that to a five-year-old yeah
no fifth grade fifth grade
that's pretty brutal yeah yeah it was
really traumatic
it's you know still sticks with me to
this day
like honestly [ __ ] her i i really don't
that teacher or like an aide or
something no it was a [ __ ] teacher
wow you got to love someone who wants to
they're like i'm going to spend my life
educating and
building the future of tomorrow wow
jackie looking pretty chunky today
yeah she uh she ended up getting fired
and i think she hated her job
so maybe that was her reason to she was
trying to try and get fired
but honestly she didn't have to inflict
trauma on you to give no right
she can go [ __ ] herself and i see her in
the street i'm gonna tell her you can go
[ __ ] yourself
oh wow you do have a lot of anger from
this yeah it was traumatic
you know whenever i talk to a therapist
and i talk about some
uh dramatic whatever or something that
happened they say if you saw that person
on the street
how would you feel so
so that answers that question for me you
still have trauma from it
unresolved trauma it sounds like yeah
you know just honestly
just who the [ __ ] does that you're
supposed to bring kids up
and make them confident tell them good
job you know not so you're looking big
today
[ __ ] you that's so horrible
oh [ __ ] elementary school that's all
would you pack for lunch today fat ass
you know it it essentially you know it
makes you embarrassing like you don't
even want to eat lunch oh i had a
i had a teacher a science teacher no he
was actually no he was an english
teacher
middle school again he's like yo
microwave straight up give you cancer
he's like if you stand he's like there's
so much [ __ ] you don't know if you just
stand too close to a microwave you'll
get cancer
yeah i was like whoa crazy i have heard
that
people say that to me a lot we'll get in
here
in the butthole cancer in the butthole
yeah
i have a ton of videos but how long
we've been going down i'm not going
anywhere i'm just curious
oh you know what's crazy moses and trish
are coming over today
for shabbat dinner yep
so your mom's cooking the whole shabbat
dinner and everything and we're gonna
host
yeah yeah that trisha
relationship is really
wait did this guy just bid on his own
bid
what do you mean by that and she only
shows this guy outlier
oh jesse withdrew his uh previous lower
bids
oh okay i wonder why what is there a
reason for him doing that or
just a style style well i think no i
think when you
when you bid it puts it it puts that
money in
escrow so you can't so wait these guys
probably remove that so that he could
then put in a higher bid
or not i don't know but i think that's
how it works yeah
so this guy outlier has he doesn't get
his previous money back
that makes sense whoa it's at 17
whoa crackers
1776 baby let's go america crazy
the kraken 1770 we got some patriotic
music going yeah
america was american independence baby
read it and weep is he american i don't
know
maybe canadian or some i don't know what
do i know
jesse the kraken out here on full
display
what was the river washington went
across the delaware the delaware
flag in hand to liberty
liberty for your currency
18 ethereum
[Applause]
oh this is crazy this is crazy it's up
to 32
000 this is [ __ ] amazing
because i made a pledge that this would
be the one and only time we make this to
keep it rare and valuable
um
do you think frenemies is included in
that
i don't i do think it's different so
maybe frenemies
but um it's up to you ultimately
i do want to say if you want any of the
other coins mining elast there's still
some left i'm going to be deleting them
they'll be all that leftovers will be
erased
should i do it like after this or like
maybe on monday
whenever this expires i think yeah
whenever this expires it's the end
oh there's an expiration date on the
other ones oh and this expires yeah when
this okay so after this
after this live then we're gonna have to
crush all those tokens
digital fire coming in
hot wow
[Applause]
just like my butthole right now fire
fire burning in their butthole
uh it was a good idea you know
kind of running out of stuff to talk
about well that's
that's what i keep saying we should ten
minutes is trying to tell you it's like
well listen i can't you can't change the
rules in the bottom of the night yes you
can
you can't be like yo by the way bottom
of the ninth inning
it's happening it's only four two
minutes long now the inning you have a
two minute timer
yes you can you only need one out this
is america
you can do whatever you want no that's
not right
you guys can go do whatever i'm gonna
sit here
[Music]
we have a family dinner no wait
um i'm trying to see what other
interesting stuff we have to talk about
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what is this i don't
even know i don't know what i'm clicking
anymore so i hope it's all good
oh that's my boy from dateline
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love this guy i watch dateline it's
sam and this girl natalie morales
okay okay
that's pretty good a little joyous
occasion there
all right yeah i don't know the outlier
is going to top this
jesse just went out up top slam dunked
so we could be out of here in six
minutes you know
could be could be or we could be here
for the next eight
oh this is dude okay this is one i sent
in
this is one that showed up on my feet
just watch this and then
first of all give me your reaction do it
again give me a reaction
i'm still filming
[Music]
so now show how it goes real when you
flatten it make it nice and
yeah yep
[Music]
[Applause]
do you really need this whole
contraption
okay but like really the spectacle is
the homie on the left right
you see that it looks like he's having a
stroke with these smalls
nice do it again
[Music]
oh sure of course yeah
his tongue
[Music]
what's he doing just
playing solitaire he's unshaken
he is unfazed by this incredible folding
thing
okay i have a theory you tell me if i'm
wrong you're wrong
what if he's watching nice do it again
he's watching a feed of what's going on
yeah i'm still filming but it still
doesn't really make sense like why is
there a feed
no i do think he's staring at something
not a fate of her
you don't think so no why is he not
caring at all about this
incredible folding do it one more time
but this time before you fold it
no i care about it it goes real when you
flatten it make it nice and
yeah amazing stuff isn't it folks do we
not have the most amazing content here
like we're going over to granddads today
right holding shirts all right we're
down to three minutes so
we got the crack up in this love the
crack
jessie you love crack don't worry it was
going to be done
at 10 that's crazy
17 yeah that's crazy 32
dollars there was predictions that
somebody someone predicted it would go
for 50
which seemed far-fetched to me although
50 ethereum didn't use no
or 50 000 oh 50 000 well we're getting
kind of close to i guess 20
well you're you're pretty close at this
point it's pretty amazing
is the kraken going to try to
assassinate me now so the spur the
purges of his coin goes up
because if i died he could resell that
for sure yeah you better watch out
oh you know he's got the means he's got
the capability
got the resources huh i don't know if i
see
that kind of personality in him
right but it's always the ones you least
suspect right
it's going to be able to be resold for i
mean multiple reasons
it's like everything's documented in
these episodes you know
everything yeah and he has the whole set
wait did it go up again
oh oh no we have another bid by this
other mystery bidder
this guy that i named yeah the guy we
have no intel on
unnamed tell us your name we don't know
who he is
wow now it's up to 19 jesse just got
cracked on
how come the numbers are so random now
is there any reason for that
uh i don't know i wonder if the bidding
increment
yeah interestingly about jesse the
kraken is that he has
all of the other cards so he'll have a
complete set
right oh i think that's why he's so
eager yeah
here's his wallet wow 100 he wants that
platinum
achievement unlock yeah i mean this guy
knows an investment when he sees it
right
i mean the guy's got the foresight of a
goddamn uh
of a goddamn guy who bought crypto early
nothing better than that
ela said privately in discord i'm gonna
out her she said we're gonna be here
forever
i but isn't that great isn't that
exciting
well it is except we do have a family
whatever they come in um i
think they're coming in maybe trisha can
come sit with me and we can have an
impromptu friend of mine
i don't think that's what she's going
for trish is always on
she's always on this is this is a big
day for her though she's probably
she's in focus mode right now she's
meeting the mom right yeah that's true
she
did if she knew how excited your mom is
to meet her
your mom's such she's gonna be great
and unlike my mom peace and love
your mama is putting a lot of effort
into her cooking peace and love peace
with comparisons you got in trouble for
this last time didn't you
no i didn't think she would be so
offended because we always joke my mom
doesn't
isn't a good cook she's not listen the
lady
she literally why did you out my
comments can we talk about that
i thought it would be funny i didn't
think it was a huge breach of privacy
it is you said we'd be here forever
i did write lol too which you did not
read
no you said lo we're gonna be here
forever lol
that's a little bit of a difference that
changes the tone does it yeah you make
it seem like i hate the show
or something oh i'm sorry you're right
well you shouldn't do that
you're right you said lol i'm sorry yeah
sorry sorry i have the unknown person
oh oh he wants to call in yeah well
bring him in
hold on zach no i i asked for proof and
you sent me
what kind of proof did you send you i
guess the screenshots that it wasn't
dating
send it to dan yeah send it to me let me
vet that because
oh jesse just came up top 20 we're up to
20 bucks
we're up to 20 each always the kraken
came in hard and fast
you cannot be defeated he's an ancient
um
he is an ancient octopus he's like god
he's an old one
or a great one bloodborne yeah holy [ __ ]
dude i just sent it to you now okay
this is insane
holy [ __ ]
i'm giving each of you guys another coin
for real i bless you
yes oh [ __ ] yeah let's go i'm giving
each of you guys
i'm ready to stick around all night
let's go and you know what uh
love i'm giving you another coin too
thank you thank you guys everybody gets
a point
thank you and i'm also gonna be donating
to um i'll be donating
to plant some trees or some [ __ ] so
people don't get angry about the
environmental thing even though i feel
like
we had a productive conversation about
it let's find some [ __ ] trees
can't hurt right and i think i'm also
although jesse is urging
us not to sell as the kraken in in arms
that's his style
but um i think i'm just going to give a
bunch to my family too
because it's all like funny money to me
you know what i mean i'm holding my
coins you're holding yep what do they
call total
total what is total hodl what is total
name
uh i don't know i have no idea what
you're talking about
in the cryptocurrency community for
holding a cryptocurrency rather than
selling it yeah they say hotel
total so it's just hold spell wrong oh
great
spelled wrong would it be i said you
were right about what
i mean about hodo because we act like it
wasn't a word
saying oh got it right i was right he
was right right right
all right everybody's getting coins here
today let's make it rain baby
[Music]
um so this proof uh does look fairly um
legit all right bring him in which guy
is the sack is it the green guy
oh yeah okay bring him in
i'm hacking your laptop to uh to get you
in there too
go ahead he said give me a couple
minutes just joined discord and still
setting everything up oh
my god interesting noob
very suspicious all right well you're
you're
well i don't want to say anything
beforehand but i was planning on
giving all this money to my family just
like my sister
my brother my parents just hooking them
up
because it is funny money and i want to
share the blessings are you giving them
the coins are you going to sell them and
give them probably not i don't know
that's
give them the option what are they going
to do with coins
my parents do you think they're going to
huddle
i don't know it's true you think my
brother has diamond hands
okay i thought they'd appreciate just
getting some money but
either thinks the ethereum might go
better we'll give them the option they
can do what they want
i feel like it's confusing when you give
them you give them too many options that
they they they go what is ethereum what
are you talking about is they're just
like here's a
check for five thousand dollars and
they'd be like oh dude
dumb but you get in those whole covers
oh do you want the ethereum because it's
this cryptocurrency
you want to have diamonds do you want
ethereum or do you want uh
wrapped ethereum which is a secondary
protocol
that can be exchanged at a one-for-one
rate with normal theory i wish i would
have asked jesse about what the [ __ ] is
rapt he was the one that yeah well
actually
all of these people are giving they're
wrapped up they're wrapped up
i looked into it it's just it's kind of
technical but it just allows you to use
it
in more places than you would wrapping
up it's wrapped up
oh are they're saying that hurdle means
hold on for their life oh okay hold on
for dear life hold on
hold on i saw an interview on
the news where someone said was saying i
hold a huddle and everyone was laughing
here let me try to find out
hodol total gang total game
let's see what's total gang oh
love said it's originally a misspelling
that's how all these things start
total interview bro this is a nightmare
i'm not gonna find what i'm looking for
i'm see i'm getting a hodor
uh right i'm looking as well
okay thank you okay peace and love peace
i am out of water you have water
i'm out we're both out i mean i spilled
a lot
maybe can we put in a request for some
water
here let me put in a request for some
water just don't know how long it's
gonna be going on for
i've been chugging in the water that's
you ian
ian's that's you how exciting is that
i found something in this one oh is this
what it is me bitcoin's extreme
hodler oh i just want to set the record
straight
it is not huddled that sounds really
stupid it's hudu
most important wait what am i supposed
to say with like a swedish accent
does it sound like a swedish accent to
you uh love i just want to set the
record straight yes
it is that sounds
it means hold on for dear life
no matter how tempting the day trade
might be
unlike other bitcoin millionaires who
cashed in their staggering returns for
lambos and yachts
we call traders traders
cryptokid keeps his paws off his
windfall
altogether believing the price of
bitcoin will skyrocket
he's currently living in a ship actually
he has a billion dollars in bitcoin but
he refuses
their genius because they put in 100
bucks and it went up to a thousand
dollars you may have just got lucky
if you can hold on to that thousand
dollars or make it grow for the next 10
years
then you're a genius in fact justin is
so
hard he's even found a way to avoid rent
i sold
all of my stuff moved into the most
frugal
living environment i could a tree house
yeah oh for real he is actually living
in a
home sweet home you actually live inside
there
on a day like today snow storm going on
yeah uh and how many bitcoin do you have
do you have um
half half of a bitcoin hold all baby
hold for life
to show you it keeps it it keeps it
heated
um we missed some great graphics
interesting
looks like jesse is rounding with two
minutes coming in at 20.
um the kraken is untoppable
this is amazing
two minutes left hey two minutes two
minutes with two minutes
out here now two minutes we got twenty
one eight twenty one eight twenty one
dude we're doing a minute after anybody
now
[Music]
all right whatever this is i know shaq's
involved it's going to be good
yeah you can come in thank you
could i could you bring me a diet coke
or a coke girl
thank you thank you thank you thank you
yeah no problem
you got it
[Laughter]
thank you elizabeth elizabeth everybody
we love her don't we folks you know [ __ ]
we always talk about shacks in every
commercial i've seen him and
i've seen him in like a lot of
commercials lately you know he's he's in
this big one for um
why is they dying
now she crapped in front of the camera
i'm sorry the way she just put it across
the scene reminding me of something i've
seen
removed before oh oh our anonymous
bitter comes up
we are up to 21 folks
hodol hodel baby [ __ ] fried chicken
i deserve fried [ __ ] chicken chicken
wednesday baby
there's actually some hype people are
watching but we want to know how big
this is gonna go
this is hype town man
it's amazing this is rare i promised you
guys coming in on this
this will be the one and only time we
meant
h3 related nfts
this is the one and only of vape nation
i i promise you that this is
we're still waiting to talk to unnamed
i think so here let's watch the shack
thing yeah i don't know word from the
guinness book of world war he just did
though right that was him
yeah yeah so he's active thank you
thank you appreciate that god bless try
to calm down
sad all right i gotta i'm here for the
long haul i got a coke zero
got this [ __ ] there's something magical
about coke zero i don't give a [ __ ] dude
i deserve coke but cooks here is so much
better than diet it's like
diet is not even drinkable right
they should have discontinued deserves
fried chicken meat i'm gonna toast to
you my friend
cheers to making it rain coins
all right let's watch shaq and that
should be a mere formality right because
you hit you hit 31 in a minute it's on
video
yeah i don't see how it could be denied
yeah definitely 31 and 31 in one minute
yeah yeah that's the record and 27 26
was the record
who there was three different guys were
tied with 26 for some years
but i mean if well i haven't seen this
guy's claiming his the world record
guinness world record i believe of uh
free throws oh my god this is not going
to go well i can tell
foreign
okay all right there you go all right
there it is see that's awesome
it's the shirt it's the shirt that's
tight oh
[Applause]
it's the shirt that's tight ernie
you know
charles barkley he's a thick ass little
he's a thick ass body
i i've seen uh charles barkley at a
casino apparently because they're a lot
in vegas
[Music]
exactly what i was thinking
this guy is like just an ordinary we
should watch that music video again
which one you don't mind oh you want did
we get claimed for that dan
did we i don't think so i don't think so
too old no one cares
you don't my ass we may have cut it out
eat out my ass
joe who would claim that can you imagine
i think so like
hey tell me how this is really hard
it's the beaches did you spell pesce so
people don't laugh at me
i just won't put it on
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you guys just send me likes just
send me links when we
what the [ __ ] was that did you show it
damn
no okay whoa what is that
it was a dead body being dragged
probably from a film i'm assuming
can someone send me that so no thank you
i saw it
oh my god i can't do this
get out my ass treat out the girls like
trash
what do we got we got six minutes left
poor jessie's probably trying to do [ __ ]
no if i can sit at his computer all day
this guy's stepping to him
unnamed all right jay station
we did a whole write up on jay station
you guys remember we did a whole content
quote about him
he got permanently banned from youtube
like leafy style
oh really totally he's done he's done
dun dun off
wow he had 6.2 million subscribers i
mean when
with content like his i'm not surprised
no i'm not surprised at all you know it
hap this happens all the time to people
where they get banned i think it's rare
where it happens to like a big creator
because you know theoretically
you learn you care about not getting
your channel banned exactly
but he had 6.2 million subscribers
apparently he had a second uh
two violations in a row
uh just got straight up boom it was
permanently demonetized back in november
no november of 16 his original channel
he's he's gone through about three or
four channels you know oh so
wow interesting how do they allow that
like it's like dude the guy is already
violating he's relentless
everywhere he's banned from youtube he's
banned from twitter he's been from
disneyland
what the frick i wish i could show you
guys his goodbye video
because his sh i'm afraid youtube will
remove no we'll get ourselves a strike
if we should yeah
he's like he goes guys thanks for all
your support
my channel is permanently banned i can
never make a new one so the one thing i
wanted to
and he does is some total sincerity he
says the one thing i want to leave with
you guys is
do not get the blank v word
can i even say it they're going to
strike down my [ __ ] channel yeah
in the context that you're saying don't
get the vaccine
he says it will kill you yeah he goes on
an anti-vaccine he goes on a long time
oh my god i do not i
i disagree i am pro-vaccine
i am not because you have to say that
everybody's like you didn't
oh my god [ __ ] you guys
i feel like station right now what the
frick what the [ __ ] is that jesse or
someone else
jesse the kraken hold on just kraken
just comes in at 25.
25. we're up to 45 000 hold the phone
where's the air horns and [ __ ] zach
let's go
i need some hype right there's some air
horses making history is this crypto
history
it's i don't really know there it is i
don't i don't think it's i don't think
that's true
it is in the fact that this is the first
wave a big youtuber is doing cryptos and
so far ethan's is the highest
not really did any other youtubers sell
why do i not believe that i thought the
logan paul one sold for like a million
dollars
oh yeah what are you doing right what's
my logan paul pogba paul sold like 3.3
million dollars of this [ __ ]
logan's not an og youtuber oh
get out of here you just blow and smoke
up my essay
still awesome though i mean i'm [ __ ]
floored this is amazing
we love you kraken and mysterious uh i
know
unnamed but the crack in you my dog boy
we dogs now
love the crack did you i think we sent
it in our group chat the other day did
you see jeffree star's nfts
oh my god no let's look at it that's a
good topic
he's doing some big and if you collab
with like a digital artist
again jeffree star another person who's
like credible allegations against him
of what actually this i think it was the
same author who wrote up this david
dobrik piece
wrote a story about oh i don't think
it's not safe for work love
send me the link i mean i just i thought
it was just his head they have
they have he has multiple ones yeah i
think maybe he's naked in some of them
no he's not naked but he's wearing like
a thong type thing can i click this
i'm not showing the screen so you can
look at it and then you'll be the judge
yeah this is what oh well
well i mean sure in the ice cream
there's it's a little butt
just a little bit [ __ ] i think that's
fine huh
i'm gonna show it okay yeah go ahead so
i mean if it's on instagram
yeah it's um he's wearing a thong but i
think
whatever he's got a lot of likes but
who cares about jeffree star man
yeah he's working with a big artist on
it so where can i see is this
up now or what's the story with the link
is in his uh bio
if you look at the bio house
but you're saying that there are
legitimate allegations
against him yeah the same the same
author who
did the david thing wrote up a big story
about how
jeff i uh don't quote me on this
here when you guys look it up because i
remember she was being like why is
nobody talking about this and it wasn't
that big of a story but
i think it was about he was making
people sign ndas and giving them
settlements who were making accusations
against him
huh yeah
yeah it was by cat why are
you so the same girl who i think has
proven herself to be a
yeah a pretty um i need to read that a
pretty reputable i mean this this girl
this girl cat 10 barge is kind of a
rising star i mean this is these are
good
journalists jeffree star accusers say
the makeup mogul has a history of
essay physical violence and hush money
offers wow
i need to read this article it doesn't
surprise me at all
you know it's crazy
so yeah seems like a really good red i
haven't read the article either i just
saw
the headline regardless i still don't
see a link to the
it's just a youtube link yeah i'm
trying to find it i know it's
oh wearable here thank you love yeah
love sent it
so this is another like nft website yep
let's see what i found interesting
though uh
is oh there's a ton of copies of them
like there's there's a few that are very
limited though it's a similar thing to
what you did
like there's some that are there's a lot
of and then some that there's wait i
think he did any one of one though this
one has four thousand copies and he's
only sold
nine of them and he announced it a few
days ago
oops the thing the thing that i was kind
of surprised with the jeffree star thing
is like
i don't see a huge overlap with crypto
bro
with crypto people well i would have
said the same about our show but
not i don't know why do you make that
assumption about jeffrey's
i think it's most i could be wrong but i
think he has mostly
young girls watching him i don't
i don't think i don't talk about it i
don't know oh
i mean it's a lot of young people in
general i think so
he probably does well he sold nine of
four thousand
of that particular one well he has been
through a lot of um
interestingly though it had 500 000
likes on it
how much it is he's selling them each
for point
he's the one that there's tons of he's
selling for super cheap
so well point one is what like 200 or
like 150 bucks something
so it's pretty expensive still uh
0.01
no 0.1 it says right here right
am i confused here well right under that
it says highest bid
oh i guess maybe it's a hybrid thing
where you find it on it oh wait now it
says
oh 28 bucks i'm so confused 0.02 by now
yeah there's like a bid thing that's
probably why not that many have sold as
most people are bidding
in like the auction style like what
we're doing for you
okay yeah see there's lots of bids
there's actually not that's all of them
oh really well there you go but the art
is really cool actually i agree with you
on that one
now this one sold for a 4 thousand
this one has sold zero i mean
hey i'm up i'm all crippled well it's a
lot though i mean
i don't know i don't i don't know if i'm
misunderstanding it but anyway if you
want to see
if you want to cr uh shout out to
jeffree star who no
not shout out to jeffrey oh oh okay we
didn't do not
endorsed whoa this shit's actually super
crazy
this artist is amazing look at this
it's kind of scary
you know what i noticed it says uh
creator jeffree star
10 of sales will go to creator you see
that on the right
10 i guess the artist is like hey listen
i don't uh where does it say that on the
right hand side
and whatever i saw it i agree okay six
minutes left what's going on over here
jesse's still killing it the crack the
crack
well so
back to j station
back to jay station he was banned his
goodbye video was basically
trying to destroy the fabric of society
urging his fans
not to get vaccinated that was his
parting message gotta love it
dude i'm freaking scared how can you be
such a [ __ ]
like that's your parting message guys
well don't forget that this was the guy
who uh faked his girlfriend's death for
views
and um bought a slave on the dark web
he faked his girlfriend's death after
they broke up thinking that she wouldn't
say anything
right yeah what the freak
is great he's made many videos about
dead girlfriends but
none that were actually in his videos
right
just that could verify that she was very
much alive
um oh he says he's claiming he's going
to sue
youtube good luck with that
jay claimed in a video posted on twitter
at 3am on saturday that the band was
random i'm going to have a channel on
youtube is going to be big but i can't
tell anybody is it going to happen
[Music]
you've already been fully demonetized
right
he thinks he's just going to hide his
face but i think he doesn't
take into account the irs and like
reporting his income
do you think he doesn't report his
income no i'm saying right now he's
saying he's going to make a new channel
and hide his face
but that won't work like eventually yeah
why
i mean if you have like a toy show or
something yeah
that's what he's planning though you're
not gonna you don't have to show his
face
but he's not allowed to have a channel i
mean like eventually they'll have
they'll know
well if he's if he's making another
corporation they won't know who owns it
but then he's also starting
like is he really going to gain the
audience
from square one maybe though he does he
is the guy has no
he has no limitation right he's willing
to do anything
true anyway uh we put together
here a little bit of a tribute
a b put this together someone entered do
not play this man
oh i have to play it jay i gotta do it
goodbye old
i'm sorry buddy i got to do it to you so
there's four minutes left and this is
for 3 40. so let me know if they start
keep an eye on yeah let me know yeah
yeah
man never forget when his eye was so
[ __ ] up and that's not fake someone
beat his ass
he just had a bloody eye for like a
month or two the thought did come in my
head
what people are gonna say online about
me
are they gonna talk about all the bad
things i did like making the ouija board
mac miller
video or xxx tentacion video
and what's even worse is are they gonna
make a ouija board video about me
chilling from the dark web even more
there's actually been slaves for sale on
the dark web guys
actual slaves that people can buy to do
everything for them guys obviously i do
not support
slavery at all guys so what's the music
is there like two songs playing at once
or is it just like creepy music his his
song is family
tonight we are going to buy one of these
slaves honestly i do not support slavery
at all where do you find this guy
who's this guy that's big ahmed
he's one of his friends yeah where does
he find these characters man
to follow every one of your orders
whether you beat them or not
and bro you're really gonna pay ten
thousand dollars for one of these
i have to pay that guys we have so much
slack here
this sleeve cannot pull with the ring
for exactly one hour guys i'm a straight
guy
are you straight i'm a straight guy i'm
not gay bro
[ __ ] okay because now i'm gay station
right now i'm gonna miss him
aren't you baby guy it was bittersweet
this is kind of like trunks
[Music]
is just all seven no way no way that's
jesus i think maybe jesus
picks up for people who need it the most
guys
like a mouse like probably a little
gerbil or something they sprained it in
blue and then
pretended it was sonic sonic
oh my god what is this thing that sonic
exc
fitted just found this website where you
can buy actual
insane people guys
she got accused for being psycho and
they put me in this insane asylum
in one of those street jackets and it
was one of the scariest thing i've ever
been through in my life
the people are crazy
[Music]
that's his girlfriend who later died
oh no not black banana
wait actually uh hold on pause it we are
under 30 seconds here
all right black santa can wait yeah this
is a big moment
there is going to clean this up he's
going to take a clean sweep at 25
eth 10 seconds the kraken
the kraken nine the crack again
it has a refresh wait there was a bid
yep
no freaking way
oh my god outlier from nowhere
outlier outlier was sick it was quietly
waiting on
[Music]
quietly waiting outlier from the shadows
from the outlands comes in
at 26 here forty eight thousand dollars
or sorry forty seven thousand dollars
we're out
[Music]
wow outlier with the dramatics what was
there like seven seconds left
yeah yeah i mean that came right down
another mysterious bitter
outlier no history
no identity nothing in his wallet
truly the outlier bear berenstain or
something
serious everyone here wow this is
truly a momentous day
wow wow wow that was close i thought it
was over
wow wow wow outlier
wow wow wow
holy [ __ ] wow
wow wow wow wow wow
this is amazing wow oh my god
i guess it's on the kraken what happened
uh um
what happened with the green guy here
who's gonna call in is he is he
um m.i.a i'm setting up but he's
having a hard time understanding discord
so i'm trying to
set it up with him that's intriguing he
knows that crypto works but he's yeah
he's gonna figure out this word
okay interesting guy anyway black santa
[Music]
he later goes what's your problem
there's nothing wrong with saying that
black santa
likes fried chicken i didn't say he was
like me like
violent or anything it's not even racist
oh
god
he just hung up on me dude he says we
need to give him fried chicken
i did like five [ __ ] questionable
videos
out of six hundred chill the [ __ ] down
oh that's like the baby in there i was
eating chicken as a black guy
negative it's not i didn't see that yeah
there's
there's something i make 600 videos of
course a few of them
are gonna have you know
our words a little bit of racism chill
the [ __ ] down
chicken as a black guy negative it's not
i didn't say they stink or they've got a
low iq no
why did you pick those at your kids
he's got such a beautiful mind this guy
he really does bro
chill the [ __ ] out you sensitive little
[ __ ] libtard wasn't that to you a b
yeah that would be sent to a b yeah
that's like we were arguing on twitter
for about two hours and it was the best
two hours of my life
it was hilarious and i was like six
videos i can name six videos off the top
of my head and then he responds like
okay so like seven
it's videos for kids bro obviously
because you're watching it yeah he told
me
oh right like you're his target audience
wow the [ __ ] down this is before i
worked for you
and he told me also uh chill out you got
your little five minutes of fame from
age three it's over for you bro
it's definitely over for him now what
the frick
i don't even have a kid audience
that's you really think there's adults
watching your [ __ ]
oh my god guys it's shawnee they're
selling slaves
they're selling slaves on the dark web
oh my god you guys
[Music]
so don't you die are you are you sharing
your conspiracy theory
about um jay station maybe
what do you mean what conspiracy
regarding what happened to us
on oh oh i mean that's up to you
oh you don't well it's just a theory
that you behave i think i think it might
be better not to just
yeah oh okay what the freak what the
[ __ ] are you guys not for me i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] but yeah
so we got the guy bring him in his name
is papa bless my bridge
right now he's on the line papa bless my
bridge
how's it going papa bless my bridge
what's up buddy
hey what's up man what's up you sound
like a young man do i have that accurate
ah like 34 okay yeah relatively young
so are you a crypto kingpin
um yeah i've been um trading like
full time for like three years now wow
what was that what do you think
full-time for like oh full-time so
what's your what's your
you're just a full-time like trader or
an investor like what is it that you do
um yeah pretty much just um just like
you know trade bitcoin and crypto for
day to day
so you are the user known as 0f287e
right
that's you is is this stuff i just i
don't want to turn that name for like an
hour now
but um it doesn't it's not letting me
out is this your first nft
purchase or are you a collector uh no
it's my first one
are you gonna are you planning on coming
over the top here we got 26 we got four
minutes left
or are you peaked out are you leaving it
to the crack and outlier
oh
it's pretty steep maybe
interesting i i'm i got you i mean it's
it's
getting high up there for sure
down to the wire three minutes here this
is exciting though did you guys ever
think it would get this high
no no not this high not this side i
really thought 10 was going to be
the the top well it wasn't moving
anywhere all all the whole time it was
like at two
but i guess i mean dan's going to the
bathroom
all right i knew there would be some
action i suspected at the end
but like wow this is crazy this is
really something
yeah i don't know yeah um i don't know
it seems like these are
these of the two really wanted a
yeah you're gonna bow out for outlier
and jesse the kraken
are you scared to go up against the
kraken because the guy seems to have
like a deep
a vault of coins like a lord of the
rings type of pile of coins you know
what i mean
oh um
i don't know who knows we'll see not
revealing your strategy
okay interesting what is your plan with
it
with the coin like ultimately would it
be to resell it for more or just to keep
it
if you were to get it right if you were
to get it total diamond hands or what
i just want to keep it for a while um
the um
it's a bit of history you know it is for
sure well i appreciate that you
appreciate that
that's awesome i appreciate that you
appreciate that that's really cool
are you are you more total on the
bitcoin do you think that what where do
you think bitcoin's going to top out at
is it still a buy
um yeah it's probably still a buy um
like i've been
like trading it full time for like yeah
three years um
i always thought it was gonna like top
out of like fifty thousand um
uh it's going to like sixty thousand
right now so
i don't yeah i don't really know where
it's going to go from now
on but um
[Music]
the kraken guy said half a million right
yeah cracking things going to half a
million
like is that absurd or is that realistic
within a
you know three to five year span from
now
i don't really know like my thing was
fifty thousand pretty much tops
um anything above that who knows sky's
the limit well let me ask you this you
how do you make money you say you're in
you trade what it how do you make money
you buy and sell or like
how do you make money i'm sorry for
being repetitive i'm just um yeah
i was um you know
it's pretty awesome that you got the
kraken got the kraken diet on your
podcast that's
pretty you know yeah that's awesome you
guys man that's awesome
yeah um so yeah like i don't know i
guess the main
three main websites that you trade on is
either
kraken binance or bitmex and um
40 seconds whoo i didn't realize we're
getting so close
we have 40 seconds outlier on top
is the krakens is the kraken oh the
kraken withdrew is bed
you know what happens when that happens
it's like uh it's like
before tsunami when the ocean recedes
the cracking is coming he's but he's got
it he's got 20 seconds he just did it he
just raised it to 33.3
no freaking way
strikes from the depths of the ocean the
kraken
strikes no
jesse that's crazy you guys jesus man
what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] we are up to
sixty thousand
dollars is this is this jesse guy the
the actual kraken dude that you
the ceo yeah yeah yeah
well hey hey hey don't worry don't
discourage
our play outlet maybe that's his
strategy oh
maybe it's just oh oh see there's a lot
of mind games going on now
kraken's one of the big dogs in the game
though
yeah when i told my uh friend uh who was
kind of helping
explain all this to me uh that the
kraken guy was calling in
he was like he didn't he was like not
believe he was like
you must be talking about somebody else
really yeah because i guess within that
world it's
a big deal i love it man we love the
kraken jesse you're the [ __ ]
man i [ __ ] like i actually learned
too i'm gonna yeah this is good
i'm gonna keep my tokens you're calling
i'm gonna hold huddle
you have to say with the swedish accent
dude jesse is like [ __ ] this guy outlier
you're a [ __ ] i'm drop i'm not even
going up by one coin i'm going up to
33.3
yeah that's uh so we don't know anything
about outlining honestly justin's
probably like a billionaire
you think so nobody knows
i was wondering you think he's a
billionaire i mean he's he's the owner
of one of the three biggest exchanges in
the world
that's wild and if he if he got that
many bitcoins that early on then yeah
he's probably
it's certainly possible right huh
yeah man um i'm just like i don't know
dude like trading from my
house man i'm not yeah slightly
different scale
than the crack but i'm impressed man you
got up there you put your money out man
21. that was a good that was a good
solid offer bro
which withdrawal you've been um jesse
let a little guy
let the little guy get ahead a little
bit no jesse keep going
he's a collector bro jesse went and
bought he has one of every
of everything he's got the whole set
yeah he's trying to complete the set
what a legend he just went to his
linkedin and says i'm not reading yeah
that's what i was going to do
i like the yeah i saw your bridge one
that's i think that's really good oh you
like dance bridge
yeah definitely see that dan try not to
sell it now everybody wants it well
thank you thank you
well now we wish we turned on the
royalties because uh
i went and got a little piece of that
action would that have felt right to get
royalties on your bridge
no it's i listen i'm happy enough with
what i got
all right um um pop what was your what
was your discord name papa bless
the bridge oh that was a reference to
the bridge did you grab yourself a
bridge
yeah do you do you have a bridge
i'll probably i'll probably buy you the
um your nft one
oh the aftermarket's gonna be popping
i'm gonna keep an eye on it
i'm sure i got a report on the
aftermarket definitely anything all
right
thank you for participating was really
fun man i appreciate you
putting getting in there and it's just
great shaking it up cool yeah appreciate
that
good luck man i wish you all the best
all right keep slamming thank you
all right man take care
yo this is some diamond-handed [ __ ]
jesse the kraken outlier we have two
big names outlier could be anyone it's
gonna be carlos
oh
he's got a thoughtful somewhere of all
those big connectors yeah i mean he's
he's uh he's the first holder okay this
is
vastly exceeding my expectation is that
60 thousand dollars
i thought 10 is where it was going to
land so not me
i believed but it's at 60
likes the highest end was like 50 and
we're like oh really
dude uh nfts baby qab
are they here yeah they just arrived why
don't you come
they can come say hi and see that what's
going on pop it off trisha is going to
want those frenemies nfts
after she sees this i love it
i love it daddy daddy well we have five
minutes i don't know if outlast
got the deep pockets for this if he
wants to tangle with the crack
i should buy crack with my money
what's in a picture of me with the crack
pipe to the crackdown what
i don't know just to complete the circle
yeah let's get some crack
hell yeah i tried crack once no i swear
to god
i was at my shady friend's house oh i
think you've told the story but i didn't
i smoked very little so i didn't feel
the effects but i did try it out yeah
yeah i tried one speed i have one gear
they're like they're like oh yeah they
brought out a crack pipe i was like are
you [ __ ] kidding me right now like is
this the kind of people i'm hanging out
with
that's a whole other level man
i know i thought i had the crown of like
the biggest druggie on this show but you
just
i've never tried crack so well
like i said i took a little hit and i
didn't feel anything so i didn't really
rip
the crack pipe too hard okay fair enough
but i did i did
i was willing to give it a shot that's
[ __ ] wild that's how i roll i have
one speed i have one gear
go
i mean it's crap yeah it's kind of
cracks up there
yeah it's not being pretty destructive
that's it if you had a tier list it
would
likely be in the s here it's uh it's
pretty serious
god bless oh did we even finish the
tribute we were getting
we were watching we did no we were at
the okay it had faded to
black and white yeah trish is here she
should come say hi because i'm out of
[ __ ] to talk about oh they're on the way
oh so they're not who was that we just
heard
not them three minutes left cracking
cracking coming in at thirty three point
three tokens
come on now jesse jesse jesse judging
the crack
33.3 now 33.3
outlier outliers come on now
any plans this weekend guys
i might watch the snyder cut you should
it was good
after all the [ __ ] you talked and you
better yeah no
you have to it's just because that's a
[ __ ] commitment in like four
you're the one that got me all crazy
about hating on that movie
and you but you you got me all worked up
and i put out these
highlights about it i sabotaged you you
know like
and now you don't even hate it
that's gonna be our most liked uh video
ever
is the the highlight of you eating crow
oh yeah i'm gonna say we definitely
gotta make a highlight like ethan
loves justice league is the greatest
movie ever made
how would it compare to the to the the
marvel
uh equivalent of like the the thanos you
know
um saga the first one was really good
honestly man i can't even hate
but like i feel people can i just i feel
like that all that [ __ ] is kind of
overrated anyway
i thought it was i thought it was
not as good as infinity war that was the
first one right
that was the first of the pair of them
yeah
because infinity war was definitely
better than end game we all agree on
that
i'd say so yeah yeah definitely
so it wasn't as good with you and that
they're over hyped i'm not the big i'm
not a marvel fan boy by any means
like they're so overhyped it's a very i
just rewatched them
they are amazing i love them
i feel the first one okay we're down to
a minute
so outlier if you're going to make your
move you better hit that track right now
get that crack pipe baby hit that crack
by get buzzing
i'm buzzing baby
[Music]
you know shit's going to happen when
jesse drew withdraws his bed
you're like oh oh like i said yeah it's
like the the ocean receding uh oh
no run shit's going down run from the
coastline
outlier you got all these bids in place
apparently you gotta retract them
i don't i mean i was just speculating on
why you had to retract i mean there's
got to be some sort of like a
escrow system to to prevent people from
baiting switching on these bids so for
sure
also you don't want to keep it public if
you could remove it i don't know
how that works but you don't want to
show your cards like you don't you don't
want people to see your previous bid
history
right right interesting high level [ __ ]
high
level mine okay 40 seconds
this might
yeah i mean it wasn't as good as
infinity war which i thought as far as
like super movie
superhero movies i saw that was my by
far my favorite that was cool
that one was cool but it's but it was
good i mean i enjoyed it
trisha is live in car she's live
she's live streaming on the way over
yeah and tick tock got to pull that over
at 20 seconds you can go live on
20 10 seconds 10 seconds coming on now
now 10 seconds 10 seconds jesse we're
cracking cracking cracking coming in on
nine
nine eight seconds eight seconds exactly
cracking the cracking
oh outliers it might be too deep
wow it's ended it's over
ah i think that's it boom
sold sold did it say sold
if you refresh you'll see it's not it's
like it's done
[Music]
you can bid on now you can bid on it you
can send cracking a bid
wow what a legend
jesse jesse h3
[Applause]
man that was a thrill that was that was
something
way beyond what i expected
[Music]
the real kraken strike sorry outlier
we loved you we appreciated you played
your best but ultimately
how can you compete with the crack
how can you can be with the crack
that was awesome thank you man thanks
for calling in too
yeah thank you that was fun so cool
champion
i'm trying to see i mean maybe it takes
a minute i don't see it on like his page
yet let me do it
yeah would you say love jesse powell one
oh he just donated as well what did he
say you want to call back in jesse
donate wait he just just donated 100
bucks just for the hell of it
with no message no message yes he just
can't stop giving much money
here get jesse back on the line thank
you thank you thank you thank you
i'm assuming he's watching jesse uh the
the same link will work if you do want
he donated 100 and said nothing what's
going on jesse you want me to give me
money go ahead man
i'll just i'll just give you my banking
details at this point you could just
send this straight to me
yeah he's wired do you want to throw us
a bitcoin too like
he basically did yeah right the amount
that he paid yeah he gave us one like oh
that's
true that's true wow
that was amazing i can't believe it got
that high that's it
that's so amazing it's unbelievable well
it's gonna be worth 10 that someday
uh it could be could be especially if he
takes you out like you said
yeah i mean what's the cost for a hit
man
high profile hat on the dart on the dark
web we should ask jay station oh
he's his but seriously how much they had
cost on a whole prof like
like probably at least a hundred
thousand or something right
um lester joe exotic what did he pay
yeah that didn't backfire that fell
through pretty badly
it didn't really happen did it so i'm
saying if he put a hit on me for like
100 200 000 you probably got a good
hit man for that you hit me you invest
that you probably double the
um 10 times the value i don't know yeah
it might not pay yeah it looks like it
just transferred
owned by jay powell so there it is
wow
thank you man that was really fun all
right well i guess we should wrap it up
i guess you guys have a uh we do have a
family there a milestone episode here
ladies and gentlemen
that is so crazy wow oh we gotta we
gotta crush the other tokens dan
or ian maybe you can do that for us
fire let's see
so there it is the transfer is complete
to jesse there you go
it'll burn and burn and burn bearings
yep wow
we gotta crush those you know how to do
that ian
i'll take care of it all right ian's
gonna somebody donated said james gave
one of his fans 50k what did you give
your fans fat ethan james gave him
i gave him a hundred thousand dollars
yeah we gave a hundred thousand dollars
this person's name is [ __ ] so uh
you can't see them oh god why this it's
just their name
it's a name yeah it's not a word it's a
name no that's their name right
right right right your name could be the
m it doesn't mean you can say it
it's with the p how was it with a p
it sounded like he said it with the p
it's a p just
yes abs right i don't know what he's
talking about but he's right
you wake up oh jesse said one second
calling
oh he's calling okay let's talk to jesse
okay
see kraken ladies and gentlemen let's
get the cracking
thank you thank you zac well pull it up
here let me pull it up that's important
live show on the computer i don't know
i never used to on no no i don't see it
when did her hair turn black
okay let's see what trish is up to on
tick tock it's always off the rails with
her
whoa
oh trish is tap dancing on david's grave
it looks like
oh my god trish is for lunch she is so
ruthless wow thank you oh we got her
live
you won't let me watch the live on my
desktop what's she talking about you
know
oh let's see i've always been vocal this
is a wig or did she dye her hair
i've always been booked on social media
because i was silently i wanted to play
it
no i don't think it's interesting yeah
okay
how could it be yeah
[Laughter]
all right i don't know i don't know
where jesse i guess
he's ready
jesse powell ladies and gentlemen the
kraken himself
calling in to celebrate his purchase of
the exclusive 101
ladies and gentlemen jesse
i give you jesse is back with us
congratulations
the proud owner of the one and only vape
god token how does it feel
uh feels like i'm about one bar
four but uh he's gonna have
the complete collection you know yes
yeah you're the only that's pretty epic
you've got all of them man
thanks took us to the other guys who who
were in there today
yeah he was in there to win it that was
pretty
do cool collect other um nfts i just
have a few others
um i haven't been like really big into
it you know i've been collecting domains
for years
[Music]
i was like big into magic and pokemon
cards
back in the day um but yeah it's
something like i'm looking more into i
think it's going to be
a bigger thing you know these like nba
top shots are like really huge
i think especially with everyone like
stuck on their houses you don't really
get a chance to like go off and like
you know trade your pogs with people or
whatever so you know maybe
the digital collector poggers
that's awesome thank you man this is
[ __ ] so cool
absolutely i wanted to ask you what's
with the what's with the wrapped
oh what's with the wrap okay yeah it's
kind of technical but
basically you have to wrap your ether
into you turn it into this other version
of ether which can interact with these
smart contracts which is like the
the auction oh okay our trading system
um
got it that makes sense got it we'll
wrap it up
well man it's so cool meeting you and
talking to you and getting to do the
whole auction so
it's just been a good time dude thanks
for thanks for
hanging out with us today that's it's
been fun thanks so much for having me
i'm happy to explain crypto to you
anytime that's great
thank you i'm sure more stuff will come
up so it'll be really cool to be able to
chat with you anytime something weird
happens or
we have questions yeah for sure i had
another idea for you
and maybe you could do a something with
teddy fresh where you give a token out
with every
piece of clothing as like a proof of
authenticity
so you buy like you know the jumpsuit or
whatever and and you get this token
and uh you know maybe it's just
something special for buying something
from teddy fresh so how would that work
you include like uh they would the
clothing would come with like a
serial code or something yeah it could
be like a code that you
you can redeem um through like you know
openc or
some other crypto app um or you could
collect this would be more
trouble but you could collect each
buyer's uh
crypto wallet address at the time of
sale and then just send them the token
you know there is a big problem of
counterfeiting like a lot of the really
high-end designer brands
that would be an interesting way of
combating
oh yeah there's there's a company called
provenance that was working on this and
and there's a couple others as well that
are like working with like louis vuitton
you know so like
every time a bag is created you get this
like unique token with it
and the shops track it and and you can
get it when you buy the bag so that
you know and then when you sell the bag
you can pass the token along to
the next buyer too so you have this
chain of authenticity like you would
with like
a high-value piece of art right like
galleries signing off
as it moves yeah so i think that's the
future
wow that's really interesting all right
we're holding tight
we're holding tight advice for the
crackers
all right buddy appreciate you man
thanks again thank you
the greatest the kraken
fear the cracking no
wow what a show well
it's friday it's [ __ ] friday fried
[ __ ] chicken day yeah
i deserve fried [ __ ] chicken
yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite nights
[Laughter]
cool where do you go he turned off his
camera
oh no i disconnected
mr kraken oh okay love you ann i'm just
curious what happened
love all you love me daddy love me daddy
so that's the show so we'll be back uh
with uh with
uh frenemies on tuesday monday for
members nice
monday night
another we'll be back for another
action-packed week
you really want a hold of those coins
what are you going to hold
what do you mean we're going to have to
debate what to do with the coins
because i wanted to cash it out and give
it to my fam
but either wants to hold well you don't
have to hold everything
right a little bit a little a little bit
of sound a little bit we're gonna
we're gonna have to get out like a pen
pencil and paper and be like
this much to hold why
why it's not that complicated i'm just
having fun
all right i'm excited to go eat your
mom's cooking i'm gonna go get it yes
all right guys everybody's demanding
trish but she's not here yet she's not
here yet we were wrong
oh another one what does that mean
what's the donor
another dono from jesse what did he say
this time
oh jessie's putting my son through
comments oh meant to say cheers to
outlier
and and
i'm not single don't show up at my don't
show up at my house not single don't
show up at my house thanks
because somebody somebody just previous
had donated and said jessie for bachelor
question mark
don't don't talk to me don't bother me
leave me the [ __ ] i'm not single parting
message from jesse
he did put it smiley at the end so it's
kind of like with peace and love
he's in love do not [ __ ] he peace and
love y'all
love him nice i'm gonna wrap it up guys
thank you everybody for participating in
what has been a land
according to abe the biggest crypto sale
in youtube history
ignoring of course the other ones that
were bigger than ours
maybe only logan paul though what you
gonna do who's the biggest to me
it's been a groundbreaking day for
carlos wow
[Music]
thanks guys so much thank you shout out
to jesse the kraken
and like you said all the the outlier
and the 8203 the green guy
yeah thx one one three wasn't that papa
blessed uh
the bridge yeah love them all right i'm
gonna go hang out with trisha
[Music]
two
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three three
you're watching h two three three three
three you're watching h two
three three
[Music]
you